one of the things that really upset me
for a long time was the fact that I had
great ideas and intentions and I wanted
to manifest them and I thought this is
how it's going to manifest and so I had
all these visions of how things were
going to unfold and then I'd started
processing it wouldn't unfold and then
it would irritate me because like I
gotta make it work I gotta make it work
ultimately I started to recognize when
things didn't work it was possibly
because there were better ways to do it
and I wasn't conscious of it and so what
I started to learn over a period of time
was simply this there's an old saying
there's a means to an end and the idea
well the end is your destination and of
course the means are how you're going to
get to that destination well of course
all of us sit down and say yeah this is
what I want and then we start to figure
out well this is what I'll do to get to
those ends I'll get to this and I'll get
to this to get to the end what I started
to realize at some point was maybe my
awareness of how to get to the end
wasn't exactly accurate and it turns out
many of the times when things didn't
work and I was like so upset it didn't
work but it turned out oh there was a
better way to get there and I didn't
even know it so the universe was really
facilitating me and I wasn't paying
attention I was getting angry at the
universe because like it's not working
in a way I want it to work and then I
started to realize some point was my God
maybe the universe has a better solution
than the one I was even thinking of
myself hey it's Evan Carmichael and I
make these videos because the thing that
saved me as an entrepreneur was watching
the stories of other successful
entrepreneurs and I learned from their
advice I learned from their motivation
and honestly I have no idea where I
would be if I didn't have those videos
to inspire me I still need them for
myself today too and I hope that they
can inspire you as well so today let's
get some incredible motivation from the
one and only Bruce Lipton enjoy thank
you
I really learned over a period of time
it's very critical insight to help me
get to where I am is to focus on them on
the end what is it I really want put
that Focus together and it's very
critical it's very interesting because a
lot of people have oh I would like this
and it's a broad General category and
then at some point it's like well it's
not specific enough you have to actually
say what it is you want I'll always
remember I was uh looking for a special
shirt to go to a Pink Floyd concert and
and I just all of a sudden visualize oh
it'd be neat to have a Russian shirt you
know with a collar that goes across here
and a couple of buttons down and I
thought oh yeah that would be really
great that would be cool shirt and then
I stopped and I was thinking where the
heck do you get a shirt like that I have
no idea in the world but I thought that
would be pretty good so I figure well I
still got to get something so I drive
off to a mall up near San Francisco and
I walk into the mall and there's a first
men's store over there and I go let's
start look and I have no idea and I walk
in and of course there's this big
circular rack of sale clothes and I
thought what the hell it's only a Pink
Floyd concert one night let's see what's
in there and I started going through the
rack and lo and behold oh my God a
Russian shirt right in the middle of
everything and it was like the shock of
oh my God there's a Russian shirt right
here
the enforce the unfortunate part of it
was I had the picture of a Russian shirt
I said cool
I never said what the color was or
anything else I just had Russian shirt
and there was a Russian shirt color gray
no color at all why I didn't put in the
concept of color and universe said well
just give it to him in Gray and it was
one of those things like oh be conscious
of what you're asking for because the
the more detail you put in
the more the universe can manifest a
resolution if you leave a lot of blanks
in what you want then all of a sudden
it's like well it's random whatever
fills in the blank because you never
said what you wanted you can have an
idea what you want and that's important
but the most important part of that just
having an idea is not just have a broad
idea I want X and I go no no what
exactly do you want why
go back to the principles of Science and
the principles of science reveal
something very important that principle
of science is this Consciousness is
creating our life experiences I go well
that sounds new agey I go no this is not
new Agee this is the primary principle
of quantum physics we are creators this
is a fact in fact quantum physics has
that but now let me add one other fact
epigenetics says the same thing because
epigenetics says your Consciousness is
controlling your behavior and your genes
and so it's time to stop for a second
and recognize where is your
Consciousness what are you thinking
about and the idea is start thinking all
those very positive thoughts but don't
try and tell the universe how it's going
to manifest okay you think of the
picture
let the universe get you there
and that's the most important lesson
I've learned I'm not telling the
universe how I'm going to get there I'm
just saying universe is where I want to
go
and then the universe will take care of
it it's so powerful it is so wonderful
and I never believed in it for the first
40 50 years of my life but I can tell
you now the life that I'm manifesting
today is a consequence of just what I
said focus on the end don't tell the
universe the means to get there your
life 95 is coming from the program
your life is a printout of your programs
you just look at your life and recognize
simple fact the things that you like
that come into your life they come in
because you have a program to
acknowledge those things but
the things you wish desire want in your
life and you work hard to make them
happen you struggle you sweat over it
I'm putting a lot of effort in I'm gonna
make this happen why are you working so
hard and the answer is whatever that
destination is your program doesn't
support it and you're trying to use your
conscious creative mind to override the
program I said Yeah by conscious mind is
five percent programs 95 percent I go
it's not gonna work very well at all so
that's why poor people stay poor and
rich people stay Rich yep that's right
the book Rich Dad Poor Dad that was
exactly what the whole point was if you
grew up with the programming of a rich
family you don't have to think
programming is subconscious your
thinking might be quite stupid I mean a
former president of ours was a
relatively rich person but not very
smart in his conscious mind but his
program was how do I got how I got rich
by what he downloaded that from his
family okay uh and if you're in a poor
family what did you download oh Life's a
struggle it's not I can't get there as
you know you can change it I say yeah
how can you change this remember I said
well there are two minds conscious is
creative wishes and desires subconscious
hard drive with a program I say the
conscious mind being creative can learn
from anything read a self-help book oh
yeah I know how to do that I said you
read the book I give you a quiz you get
a hundred and it says yeah you know this
stuff and then I say well now that you
know this stuff did your life changed
and the answer is no now
I go why the conscious mind learned from
reading a book that's not how the
subconscious mind learns so our smarts
stay up here I read the book I knew the
information I understood how it worked
blah blah blah blah blah I go yeah
that's the thinking mind that knows but
I go does that translate into
subconscious it's like no it doesn't
because that's not how the subconscious
mind learns you want to change the
subconscious then you have to put in the
data the way the subconscious mind
learns conscious mind creative can learn
from anything you could just go aha I
just changed my mind I can do that okay
subconscious mind habit point of habit
it resists change if a habit changes and
by definition it's not happen anymore so
habits resist change and yet we have
these habits and we want to change them
I said how can do and I say the only way
you can change the habits is the way
that the habits were learned in the
first place like well what was that I
said first seven years your brain was at
a lower vibration than Consciousness it
was called Theta Theta is hypnosis and I
go oh so what do I do I say well you you
can't just say Okay I want to go into
hypnosis hypnosis is part of a scale of
low vibration going high during the day
and then when you come home from work
the high vibration slows down and goes
to sleep at the lowest vibration so you
go through a range of different
vibrations as you're sleeping Awakening
calm conscious focused conscious you're
at work focused conscious and I go then
what you come home you calm down now
it's calm conscious and then I say what
then you fall asleep
I said the instant you fall asleep the
next vibration down is Theta I go that's
hypnosis I go yeah so I say then every
night
the moment you fall asleep the brain for
a short period of time is in hypnosis
Theta so I say so what well you put on
earphones or ear plugs and you go to bed
playing a program that you want to be
true in your life I say so what I say
you put it on just before you fall
asleep and while you're still awake you
probably hear some of the program okay
but the moment you fall asleep conscious
Minds disconnected doesn't hear anything
coming off of the program anymore I say
but what does I say ah
the subconscious mind is in Theta record
so whatever's coming through the
earphones is not going into conscious
mind but it's now being directly
downloaded into the subconscious so this
is called self-hypnosis you have to
repeat this process because the amount
of time in Theta is relatively short
before before you hit the lowest
vibration Delta which is sleep outright
okay so every night when you go to bed
just after your Consciousness falls
asleep there's a period of record
opportunity and then we put the
earphones on play the program is called
self-hypnosis that's hypnosis you're
doing it yourself okay number two you
still learn programs after age seven you
learn how to drive a car you learn how
to play an instrument I go well how'd
you do it that way I go repetition
habituation is practicing something and
repeating it and repeating it so many
times that the subconscious finally says
okay I got a pattern I got the pattern
and that pattern then becomes the Habit
Consciousness is creating your reality
if you put a picture of fear into your
reality then your biology Behavior will
manifest things to be afraid of because
this is a short statement but to me it's
the most powerful one simple and short
and it goes like this the function of
the mind is to create coherence between
your beliefs and your reality if I have
a negative belief the function of my
mind is to manifest Behavior to
experience those negative realities if I
have positive beliefs then the function
of my mind is to manifest the positive
experience but we got programmed with so
many negative beliefs and that takes
away our power because we're not
focusing on the beautiful things we're
focusing on the fear what are you afraid
of that 95 of your life is coming from
observing the other people not observing
you but observing the other people and
so your behavior isn't yours now Steve
brings up the most important question
well how do we change these behaviors I
go first of all you don't even know what
the behaviors are because you weren't
there when they were being program
I don't know what my behaviors are what
what did you learn when you were in
utero oh you don't know oh okay what did
you learn during the year from zero to
one oh oh you weren't there you don't
remember oh what what did you learn from
one to two and I'm saying your conscious
mind wasn't working at that time so
whatever happened it's not in your
conscious mind and so the significance
about all this is profound because what
the significance is
then you don't know your program you
don't know your program and I go oh so
what are my programs and now thank God I
can tell you what your programs are
because of this
95 of your life is coming from the
program your life is a printout of your
programs you don't have to go backwards
in your life you could just say where
where am I today and here's a simple
point so all of you out there ready
the things that you like that come into
your life
they come in because you have programs
to acknowledge them
but
the things you want the things you
desire and you have to work hard you
have to sweat I'm going to make it over
I'm going to sweat over this I can put a
lot of I'm putting a lot of effort I'm
working real hard to make this
why are you working so hard
the answer is whatever that destination
you were trying to get to your
subconscious program does not support
that destination and that's why your
conscious mind is working so hard to get
there so I say you got programs and you
got them before you even knew you were
being programmed and then we have to
identify those programs because if you
want to change your life
and you want to make it one that has
wishes
then you have to assess where your
program is now so that you can then
change those programs and create the
life you want also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I designed a special free
work worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
there's an old phrase that I'm right
that is just a stock phrase of the world
because it's truism it says knowledge is
power and everyone goes oh yeah
knowledge and I go no no
let me say in a way that might be
relevant to us now I say a lack of
knowledge is a lack of power
and I say we have been deprived of
knowledge of who we really are how
powerful we are because all the
knowledge we get in growing up is how
weak we are how vulnerable oh my God
viruses are coming parasites are coming
blah blah blah blah blah blah
everything's gonna fall in a bar and I
go well that's not true
it is true if you don't recognize your
power and I say well what power and I go
well one of the first things that this
empowered us was the belief that genes
control our life oh why is that just
some power us I go well simple point
it says that as far as you know you
didn't pick the genes you came with
if you don't like your characteristics
you can't change the change you came
with and then I add this little last one
the creepy one that says well the genes
turn on and off by themselves without
you I don't know why it's relevant well
if the genes are controlling my life and
they turn it on they're turning on and
off without me I am definition a victim
of my heredity oh there's heart disease
running in my family oh I'm gonna get it
cancer oh I'm gonna get the cancer it's
him running in my jeans I go
that's a bunch of BS oh that means
belief system
why is that relevant I say because the
idea that genes turned on and off by
themselves is the biggest false story
that you bought into which took away
your power because it says Change
Control you you don't control your genes
and that's why you look at your fate is
what James did my mom and dad give me
because my future is going to be
determined and I go completely false
genes cannot turn on and off and I go
we've been programmed interned on cancer
Gene turned on gave me cancer I go no
a gene is a blueprint to make a protein
this and I go okay let's unpack that I
go the body that you see in the mirror
look on the screen see yourself all that
and I go that is made out of protein
building blocks they're about a hundred
thousand different protein types that
come together assemble them together and
I make a muscle cell out of some
proteins make a brain cell out of some
other different proteins so if I you
know try to tell the audience I say well
proteins are like Lego kit Lego Parts
they got a hundred thousand different
pieces different shaped pieces and I say
how you assemble the Lego can create a
muscle cell or how you assemble them can
create a brain cell a skin cell and I go
so the point about it is this proteins
are the building blocks but proteins
break down so you have to replace them
but I go oh they're very complex
molecules I go
where do we get that the proteins when
they break down I go we have DNA I say
what's that it's a blueprint on how to
make a protein I go so what I go it's a
blueprint and a song I go
this is the story I always say so you go
into an architect's office and she's
working on a blueprint and I say lean
over her shoulder and go hey tell me is
your blueprint on or off
and she was looking to go what are you
crazy it's a blueprint there's a there's
a one and I was a boyfriend they go aha
you're finally gonna get it a gene is a
blueprint it does not turn itself on and
off it doesn't know what it does it
doesn't know why it's needed as no
knowledge other than how to make a
protein and I go but you gave power to
the genes that's what we did oh the
genes control me and I go no it's like
the architect story there's a blueprint
blueprint doesn't work by itself but it
works with an architect who can read the
blueprint and even modify the blueprint
and I go oh well the genes of the
blueprint then who's the architect I go
our Consciousness is ultimately
translated into chemistry that goes into
the blood
and that chemistry is what controls our
genes there are three ways to change
belief okay
self-hypnosis earphones on at night
repetition create a new habit
and third one energy psychology which
allows you to rewrite an existing
program in minutes uh and we need to do
this why
because if you haven't noticed and you
haven't looked out the window the
world's falling apart I go and why is it
falling apart and the answer is because
we're facing what is called the sixth
mass extinction of Life the web of life
is collapsing I go then why is the web
of Life collapse and answer is human
behavior
I go oh
you don't want the web to collapse
we have to change a behavior
and this is what the world is
experiencing at this time the chaos all
over the world is bringing to light the
fact that these behaviors were fighting
and violently with are behaviors that
have taken us out of heaven
and put our Consciousness into a world
that we're experiencing which is falling
apart you want to make a world of heaven
then you change the program and then you
can have Heaven it's your belief system
that that creates this you fell in love
because you stopped playing your program
and you created heaven
I say well guess what heaven was always
there except the damn program got in the
way so you want heaven on Earth
don't play the program stay mindful or
be rewrite the existing program and put
heaven on Earth programs in there and
then 95 of the day you'll be playing
that negative thinking is equally
powerful but works in the opposite
direction meaning with positive thinking
you could heal yourself many disease
with negative thinking you can die and
create any disease you can create your
own death just because you believe
you're going to die and all of a sudden
I say well then it's the power of belief
positive or negative that is shaping the
world and I go well this is why when we
look at people's beliefs and and they
they do a you know an assessment of they
find out over 60 percent of the beliefs
that we're manifesting every day are
negative and disempowering
self-sabotaging thoughts that we've
acquired such as I'm a victim of my
genes that's a belief and somebody says
yeah well I'm going to die of cancer
because it's running in my in my family
and they get cancer and then they find
out
there's no Gene that causes cancer oh oh
I'm saying this on on Lynn show I will
have to emphasize that there is not one
gene that if you have this Gene you have
cancer genes are correlated with cancer
genes are not causing cancer this is why
half the women that have the breast
cancer Gene brca2 half the women never
got the cancer but they all possess a
gene so where's the point it says the
gene didn't cause it it was a lifestyle
that was not in harmony that ultimately
activated what is called a cancer Gene I
said so what do you mean so if you
change your thoughts and get rid of
cancer I go yeah well that's what
spontaneous remission is all about uh
and so I'm stepping on linsfield here
because this is where this emanation of
thought
and we don't see it and we don't in our
history oh that's just thoughts and
feelings I go those are the controls
that are manifesting your life your
thoughts and your feelings your feelings
are the translation of the energy into
sensation so your feelings are like a
compass they're telling you whether
you're going toward more life or to less
life the most important aspect about
sleep is that it gives a chance for the
body to recalibrate its system so when
Consciousness is out then uh the body
starts to balance everything that's
going on you know with each system the
body's pH the temperature regulation
very interesting point that when people
are comatose in the in a hospital and
they got all the wires on them and
everything they run at a beautiful just
just beautiful like idling speed they're
comatose but their body is maintained a
balance and Harmony and everything is
great in the body level but as soon as
they become awake then the parameters in
the body all start to change because
it's our Consciousness that is creating
the the functions of our body uh and
it's really important for people to
understand this is that quantum physics
is the most valid sign on this planet in
regard to its theoretical insights
um and the number one principle in
quantum physics is consciousness is
creating our life experience that's the
most important understanding because it
says we're not just a a machine but
we're like a remote control machine
there's a uh an energy field that is
being picked up by each of us that is
different uh the the field that's being
received is different for each person
what is the immune system
well generally it's something that
protects me from what
from things that get inside your body
and I said well why should things want
to get inside my body in the first place
let's set up a scenario
you're out there in the world and I drop
you off in the wilderness and I say okay
survive
and one of the things you have to do is
start finding food and you're going to
spend all your time maybe find nothing
and you're going to be looking for food
and here's an alternative Vision I drop
you out and eat all you can Buffet well
you don't have to worry about food it's
being served to you all the time what
does this have to do with the immune
system and I go like this
bacteria parasites that live out in the
environment have to struggle for their
survival to find food
but underneath your skin the tissue is
inside your body are flush with fluid
from the blood and in that fluid or all
the nutrients and elements necessary for
growth so if a bacteria could find
itself inside to your body it would be
sitting pretty all I'd have to do is
just sit there and food would be
constantly delivered from an individual
circulatory system
so the idea is well yeah then obviously
this is a nice environment that uh
invasive organisms would like to find
themselves in because it's like free
food what you know no probs so okay so
what does this mean it says well then we
have to have a defense system because if
invasive organisms get in there not only
will they utilize the food we make but
they could create a toxic waste
environment that could actually
undermine our health so we can't afford
to have invasive organisms come into us
and take over and the immune system's
job is an internal protection system as
opposed to for example the adrenal
system fight or flight which protects
you from threats on the outside immune
system protects you from threats on the
inside so I said well how does it work
well the immune system is an intelligent
system because what is the function of
the immune system to go out into the
world of their body and look for things
that are new that came in and then not
only recognize them but learn about them
so that they could create antibodies for
example to effectively knock them out so
the immune system's character is
learning and memory I go wow what a
coincidence this is the character of the
nervous system point
the immune system is an extension of the
nervous system learning in memory about
the environment in which you live so I
said well how does it work well I say
that there are organisms that prefer to
find the interior of our body as a place
to live because it's so much easier for
them just to sit there and live off of
your energy and your nourishment so the
old story is oh the immune system
protects self my body against invading
organisms as everything else is called
knob cell well I go that's a crude
Insight but it's not anywhere near
accurate for a simple reason
the immune system identifies things that
get into the body that cause disruption
of the system and its job is to identify
them mark them and eliminate them and I
go but there you know there are many
organisms that live with us that are
part of us it's called the microbiome
thousands of species of organisms
bacteria and parasites living with us I
say the immune system doesn't attack
them the reason is this they support our
viability they support who we are so
self versus not self that's not the
discriminating factor of the immune
system factor of the immune system is
anything that's disruptive to the system
well guess what that not only includes
organisms that came from the outside but
even our own cells if they go Rogue like
go into a cancer State the immune
system's job is to eliminate them so
basically the functional immune system
is to keep Harmony in the system any
organism that comes in that disrupts
Harmony functions immune system do the
affirmations you started to implement
when you saw this depressed thoughts
coming in or these self-sabotage
thoughts coming in what did you shift it
with affirmation with different thoughts
that's the awareness a that you know as
I said the very first stop light where I
started all of a sudden listen while I'm
waiting for the light it was like the
first time I tuned in and go what the
hell are you thinking
that was the most important thing
because then the habit of
not going there anymore starting to
realize oh this is why am I thinking is
that anything turn around make a
positive statement right now because
that negative one is taking you and just
a repetition of this Behavior become
habitual so and habits are great why no
effort I love habits why you don't even
have to think about them they do it
automatically you know so if you put in
these really great habits you can walk
through the day and think anything you
want do anything you want and your habit
if they're good ones will just guide you
perfectly through here without even
being involved with thinking
um that's the game the game is what has
happened to you
then program that that's your life and
then guess what the 95 percent of the
day manifesting Heaven well you're not
even thinking about it once you have
identified your programs
how can you change what do you do with
them and that always comes up because
that's the most important question after
you understand how it works the most
important question is well how do I
change the program
and I go this is the critical part
the conscious mind is creative which
means it can think of anything
the subconscious mind is programmed it's
got habits I go so what I say habits
when you have them it's a habit you do
not want to change a habit which is
important you learn how to walk before
you were too I'm glad you don't change
your habit because you'll forget how to
walk I say nope same program you learned
before too can carry you a hundred years
same program okay habits do not want to
change because if a habit changes then
by definition it's not a habit so the
subconscious mind is habit mine I say
yeah but how do I change I say there's
three ways only
that you can control this
number one how to get the habits in the
first place I say for seven years my
brain was at a low vibration called
Theta which is just below Consciousness
and Theta is the direct hypnosis line to
the subconscious so when you're in Theta
whatever you're experiencing at that
point can be downloaded straight into
the subconscious I said well how do you
get the Theta I say
interesting every day when you're up at
work you've got a high vibration in the
in the brain that's again with the wires
on your head EEG
the high vibration is called beta that's
like School room studying focused
Consciousness when you come home and
relax the vibration goes lower now it
goes into what is called alpha alpha is
calm relaxed Consciousness but when you
get really calm and you're really
relaxed guess what
Alpha shuts off you're sleeping when
you're when Alpha is off you are
sleeping but for the next period of time
right after you fell asleep the brain is
operating in Theta and then it goes to
the lowest vibration deep sleep Delta so
Theta is a period when your mind goes to
sleep it's open for a little while and
Theta is hypnosis so if you put
earphones on
and you play a program at night when you
go to bed every night you go to bed just
before you fall asleep you put the
earphones on you play a program of a
program about health a program how to
make money a program how to be you know
relationships self-help program okay at
night you put the earphones on when you
go to bed
and as soon as you fall asleep you're
not awake anymore Alpha close you're in
Theta record whatever is coming in
through the earphones is not going into
the conscious mind it's going deeper
into the subconscious it's called
self-hypnosis
you put the pro you put the earphones on
you repeat that because Theta is not a
long period after you fall asleep but if
you're repeat it every night you'll get
information into the subconscious so
number one self-hypnosis earphones out
at night play a program that you want to
be true okay and then it will
automatically happen this is a
demonstration that and it's fun why you
were sleeping you didn't even have to do
any work you just have to go to sleep
and the work would be automatic so when
you wake up after playing this at night
uh the subconscious will have a new
program and one day you'll wake up and
you're living the new program without
even playing the tapes anymore it's once
it's in it's in okay so number one is
hypnosis self-hypnosis okay
but after age seven the brain is not in
hypnosis
and now Consciousness is working I said
but you can still learn a program you
could learn a habit I say how practice
repetition you want to drive a car well
I'm not getting in the car until you
practice why because it's the practice
that makes the program strong energy
psychology is a new version of
psychology that engages something called
super learning super learning what's
that I go maybe seeing somebody read a
book by moving their finger down the
page just as fast as they move that
finger down the page they read
everything about you know on the page on
both Pages boom they could just read it
so the idea is this well if you can
engage super learning
and use that in downloading a new
Behavior you ready you can change a
belief you had your whole life 50 60
years you can change that in minutes
because super learning is the equivalent
of pushing the record button on on the
subconscious super learning allows you
to download a new program in minutes and
we need that why because the behavior
that the culture and civilization using
today is so out of harmony with nature
that humans are causing their own
Extinction at this moment it's called a
mass extinction NASA scientists have
already told us that industrial
civilization the one we're in
uh is facing and I want to emphasize
this because it was in the title of
their report and I just I said we are
facing an
irreversible collapse of civilization in
the next couple of decades well we're
seeing it right now civilization is not
working the chaos that's all over the
planet is a sign that it does not work
this way and if we don't change then
we're facing our own Extinction in all
biological organisms there's something
referred to as the biological imperative
the biological imperative can't be found
by biologists there's no place I say oh
here it is in the South but what it
represents is the drive to survive when
we start to feel that our life is
threatened
it's not a conscious at first it's a gut
feeling it's visceral something in my
gut says something's not right this is
the biological imperative looking at
your potential future in the world that
you're living in
and what we really have to recognize is
that people are feeling it in their gut
the world is not right it's not right I
go well this is wonderful because this
is a feedback system that's saying the
world in which you live is not in
harmony with you
and therefore what it really means is
that we have to change how we influence
the world in our own way and it says
that if we start to change and send out
love instead of just receiving fear
that the love we send out has two two
aspects yes there's an external
consequence of love it influences
everyone and everything around me
there's a profoundly different chemistry
if I have a thought of love coming into
my body which you can feel when you're
in love you can feel it yes your cells
are bathing in chemistry of love but
when you have fear it's a different
chemical response it gets you girded up
for response protection Walling you off
from the outside I don't want that thing
to come in and take care of you know my
inside and I say well what's the
relevance and the answer is very simple
the chemistry released by the brain and
fear shuts down the growth mechanism of
the body shuts down the maintenance of
the body to conserve energy and the
biggest thing is there's only one
consequence and that is disease and
illness and it turns out one percent of
disease on this planet is connected to
genetics
ninety percent of disease or more is
lifestyle and the psychology of love and
fear
90 percent
and says be in love and your body will
be maintained and your immune system
will be at Peak Performance be in fear
and the game is over the brain is a
computer that's a clear fact and it has
the same functions and and systems as
our silicon conventional computer that
people is watching right now and so
here's the Insight I get a brand new
computer I got out of the store and I
push start and it boots up what does
that mean the screen lights up I say oh
great got a brand new computer let's do
a drawing let's do a story a spreadsheet
and I say no I can't do it I say why not
you got a brand new computer you say not
until I put programs in the computer can
I use that computer
and so I say oh and then after I got the
programs in then I can type and I can
interface the computer but I without a
program I can't do anything the human
brain as a computer gets programmed
starting in the last trimester of
pregnancy through age seven because the
brain function is not high enough for
Consciousness most of the time it's a
little lower and I say that's what we
said Theta hypnosis I say why is it
relevant the answer is very important
how many rules must a child learn to be
a member of a family and a member of a
community there's thousands of rules to
be of you know a person in the community
like a an infant can't read the book I
go no the infant brain is actually like
a video recorder it watches the mother
it watches the Father the siblings it
watches the community downloads their
behavior those are the programs
after age seven a child then can work
the computer and do what it wants okay
so I basically say so it started in
utero this is how uh um a mother can
play music uh through her abdominal wall
you know put the speaker there uh and
repeat that music and guess what when
the baby's born she plays that music the
baby instantly knows that music or the
father talks to the baby through the
abdominal wall uh and repeats this and
when the baby is born the moment the
father says something the baby will know
which one the father is because it
already memorized this stuff it
memorizes what the mother eats ah
because of the nutrition coming through
I say how does all this work simple we
talk about the blood is the culture
medium with the chemistry that
determines the genetics and I go so why
is a relevant I say then whose blood is
the fetus using in development I go the
mothers so I go so why is that
irrelevant well if she's having an
emotional response that's chemistry and
I said she's feeling that emotion
whether it's wonderful love or fear and
I go so why is it relevant that blood
with the same chemistry of the mother is
going into the fetus I go why is that
Robin the fetus feels what the mother
feels if the mother is under stress and
the fetus is getting an experience that
life is very difficult up there if the
mother is feeling love and support and
everything then the life is easy for the
fetus it started learning in the last
trimester
but then for the next seven years it
does the same and I go so why is
irrelevant I go
once I get past age seven my
Consciousness can type on the keyboard
so I can program what I want and then
here comes the monkey wrench and the
monkey wrench is this the conscious mind
which types can think and you go so what
I go thinking is inside
you know if I ask you Jennifer I say uh
tell me what you're doing uh you know on
Tuesday yeah and right away you can tell
me but you'd have to think oh Tuesday
what am I doing on Tuesday I say what's
the point
the conscious mind when thinking stops
looking out at the world and the
conscious mind looks inside so what if
you're driving your car and you're
driving down the street and all of a
sudden you have a thought and I say oh
conscious mind just not not looking out
anymore I said oh my God I'm gonna crash
the car because of my Consciousness is
inside I go that's when the subconscious
when the conscious is thinking the
subconscious is autopilot and takes over
like so why is it relevant I go now
science is recognized 95 of the day is
the average person's amount of thinking
okay so why is it relevant well if a
conscious mind has your wishes and
desires and subconscious as your
programs is your life coming from your
wishes and desires I go up five percent
95 percent of your life is whatever the
hell the program you got from that seven
years is going to play and if you've got
a program that's not supporting you then
95 of the day your behavior will not
support you because that program doesn't
encourage you okay uh I always give the
audience the same story for 40 years now
and you know the story but I'll tell
your community I guess you have a friend
and you know your friend's behavior and
you happen to know your friend's parent
and one day you see your friend has the
same behavior as their parents so you
really want to tell you're afraid to go
hey Bill you're just like your dad I
said back away from bill because I know
what Bill's going to say the first thing
you said how can you compare me to my
dad I'm nothing like my dad in the
audience laughs I go that's the most
profound story in the world right now
I'll tell you why
everybody else can see that bill behaves
like his dad who's the one that doesn't
see it Bill how the hell does that help
I go because when Bill is thinking he
lets go the control and while he's
thinking the behavior is playing but
because he's not even looking out at his
own behavior he doesn't even see his own
behavior yes so in his mind no I'm not
like my identical but everybody else can
see you behave like your dad you're the
only one that can't see it and I go so
why is it relevant and the answer is
simply this we are all built we all have
beliefs wishes and desires and then we
have to say how come I'm not manifesting
the world I want how come I'm not as
healthy as I want to be how come not
creating the life I want if my mind is a
Creator and I go it is the creator but
then I tell you which mind are you
operating from
and 95 of the day you're not operating
from conscious wishes and desires 95 a
day the subconscious programs are
automatically playing I go what if those
programs are not any good I go
well you won't see it they'll just be
playing you know what you'll see the
result so I very simply I wake up in the
morning with conscious mind today I'm
gonna go find love today I'm gonna get
healthy today I'm gonna get the best job
and then at five o'clock you'll come
home and go oh didn't happen it didn't
happen and I go then what does that
person think because they're like Bill
they go oh everything's against me the
universe against me
this person is responsible that person's
responsible for not letting me get my
wishes and desires I go no
all day long you were shooting yourself
in the foot with your own behavior and
you didn't even know where the gun was
coming from it was in your own hand and
I say so why is a relevant we have been
programmed to believe that when it
doesn't work we are victims of the
outside when the truth is no 95 percent
of the day we were playing programs that
did not support us and as a result the
end of the day we didn't get that
support but we didn't see it why
subconscious was below conscious was
controlling your life your conscious
mind is I'm going to be healthy I'm
going to fall in love and I go that's
great but that's five percent of the day
yeah but 95 I go I'm coming from a
different program and so when you look
at your life and this is a beautiful
part you can say what are my programs I
just want to help people right away I'll
tell you what your programs are and you
say well how do I know I was being
programmed before I was born I was
programmed from zero to one can you tell
me what program you got when you were
zero no you didn't tell the program you
got a one no can you tell me the program
at two no about three you might say oh I
remember some things but I say you've
been essentially programmed with no
awareness of the program so you didn't
even see the program and now I say so
what is your program you go
I wasn't there now I give you the answer
and you're ready 95 of your life comes
from the program your life is a printout
of your program look at your life right
now and I'm going to tell you this very
simple the things you like that come
into your life they come in because you
have a program to print them in yeah the
things you want Health relationship good
job your struggle you're working hard
you're putting a lot of effort in I'm
gonna make it happen I'm sweating I'm
going to work hard
why are you working so hard and the
answer is simply this your own program
doesn't support that you're trying to
override the 95 percent of the day that
that negative program is playing with
five percent effort going oh I wanted to
be successful I go yeah 95 of the day
you've got what are you get from your
parent not smart enough not deserving
not good enough not lovable these are
things that we've downloaded in the
first seven years
and a very interesting fact is this for
400 years the Jesuits have told their
followers the absolute truth and nobody
understood what they were talking about
I go what do you mean they would say and
this is a fact for 400 years they would
say give me a child until it is seven
and I will show you the man
what the hell does that mean the answer
is just as I said science has said the
first seven years you're in Theta
program
that's where you're learning then I said
but what about the rest you'll have to
go 95 of the rest of your life program
so if I can control the first seven
years I control the rest and that's what
they said give me a child until seven I
will show you the man meaning if you let
me do the first seven years of
programming I will tell you how that
child's life is going to work out I
asked a question to the universe which
then myself answered I asked a question
when I just realized and owned I exist
as a
field energy a spirit whatever you want
to call it as information in the field
and it also exists as a body my first
question that came up in my head was
then why have both why have a spirit and
a body why not just be the spirit
and my cells came up with this chorus
that I just blasted my head and it was
kind of funny because I I think they
have Jewish Heritage cells because I
asked them a question and they responded
in a question I asked why have both
and all of a sudden the welled up and
the answer came and said Bruce if you're
just a spirit
what does chocolate taste like
and all of a sudden I said oh my God
it's the biology which is all the
receptor devices that translate my
environment into sensation which are
then translated by the nervous system
into fields and and vibrational patterns
which are then sent back to my source
and I realized at that moment I said my
God that we're here to experience this
place to touch it and smell it watch
sunsets and feel love and and and and
eat wonderful food and have all this and
I thought wow and then all of a sudden I
said yeah but it's not just receiving
information
when you have a body you can be creative
we can come to this planet and manifest
creativity
and we do this we step into a virtual
reality suit called the body I step into
the suit as a spirit it communicates
with me via just the same way the Mars
rover is communicating with NASA and I
get to experience this planet the belief
that Gene's turn on and off is taking
power away from the individual because
if the genes were turning on and off and
I did not control them then by
definition I am a victim of which genes
did I get from my family did cancer
genes come in the heart disease genes or
diabetes and now we recognize that in
regard to disease genes are responsible
for less than 10 percent of disease in
fact there are indications that genes
are only responsible for one percent of
disease so all of a sudden it says well
wait we used to think genes cause
disease but if only a small percent of
disease is controlled by genes and where
is the disease coming from that is
affecting the world the answer is now we
know from epigenetics Consciousness
lifestyle belief systems these are the
ultimate controls of the gene we know
that if you've got a cancer Gene and
that's what you believe then you think
I'm going to get the cancer and then you
get a Cancer and you say the genes did
it and now we know no that there is no
cancer Gene there is not one gene that
causes cancer genes are correlated with
cancer meaning if your life is not in
Harmony and you have one of these genes
you can activate a cancer
50 percent of the women that have the
same brca1 gene never get the cancer the
point is very important having the gene
doesn't mean you've got cancer but
having the Gene and not living in
harmony not living in a healthy
lifestyle that causes the cancer
and so we have to help people take them
from the belief I'm a victim and give
them the science that no your
Consciousness is creating this life
experience in here your Consciousness is
controlling your genes in the past if
you looked at it people have perceived
themselves as victims of everything
around them victims of circumstances and
then we go oh I'm I'm sorry life did not
give me those wonderful things that
other people have and the simple reality
is no no if you have an issue it's not
the outside this is what we've always
old Universe give me something we now
know that our issues are internal it's
our own subconscious beliefs that we've
been programmed with of disempowerment
like when a child is growing up and
getting its programs think of what
things parents say oh you don't deserve
this who do you think you are I mean the
parents didn't mean that for your whole
life they just they were trying to you
know goju you know it's needle you to
make a change so they would save these
things
95 of our life comes from those programs
so if you have disempowering beliefs
about who you think you are because you
got them from other people that's how
you know who you are
these disempowering beliefs play 95 of
the day in an average person's life
so I say Yeah well my wishes and desires
I want success I want great
relationships I want all these wonderful
I want health I go well that's conscious
Minds because conscious mind's creative
but uh as science reveals only five
percent of the day are we operating from
our own personal wishes and desires 95
of the day we operate from the programs
that we got in the first seven years and
if those programs which psychologists
have told us 70 percent are negative and
disempowering and self-sabotaging they
say good apply these 95 a day in your
life and you realize why your life is a
struggle it's not a struggle because the
universe is not providing it's a
struggle because your own Consciousness
is not accepting and this is where we
have to change and so getting control of
your mind taking charge of your
Consciousness is a way of overcoming
those limitations there are many
different ways to to take this control
back in in your life and one of them is
the ability to uh like in yoga for
example to be the master of your mind
and not let it run the monkey mind let
it run no I want this I don't don't let
this other one go the world is in a
state of evolution and what I mean by
evolution is not a physical Evolution
humans are not going to change into
something different
the evolution that we're really
experiencing now was an evolution in
consciousness
a Consciousness that has in the past
separated us as individuals
a Consciousness that has been programmed
with a belief that life is a struggle
and that we're out here to survive we
have to be in competition with each
other and undercut and undermine and we
were acting as individuals looking for
our own individual power
but in today's world there's a new
understanding that the evolution is an
evolution of Consciousness an evolution
of an expansion of we are more than just
these physical entities
that there is an energy involved in
Newtonian physics the conventional ones
that most people have learned atoms are
physical particles like little granules
but in 1925 physicists came to another
understanding because they said so what
are those particles made out of you
called atoms and they went inside and
they found they were smaller so-called
particles electrons protons and neutrons
but that still wasn't the quest because
what are they made out of and that's
when the world changed because when
Quantum physicists started to say what
is an electron or a proton or a neutron
made out of it's made out of energy not
physical no substance an atom is like a
nano tornado a spinning force field
there's an illusion that we are physical
entities you're an energy field
I go so what the heck difference does
that make and I go well here's the
interesting part particles I can
separate here's a particle here's a
particle let's talk about one particle
energy just mixes all together I'm
sitting in a field of energy right now
so if I'm made out of energy which I am
does it mean that the edge of my energy
stops right here and the answer is no
and quantum mechanics I'm an energy
field wherever I go I'm like a broadcast
broadcasting and energy to wherever you
are right now you're broadcasting energy
and so in a Newtonian world we grew up
with this is separate from this and
that's separate from this and I go in a
quantum mechanical world nothing is
separate everything is an energy field
with no borders to it so what I do in my
world is not just what I do in my world
what I do in my world is broadcast
through everything else and if it
resonates or is in harmony with you my
energy can affect your energy or my
energy can actually cancel your energy
everything is interconnected the chair
I'm sitting on is energy the air I'm in
breathing with is energy I'm energy your
energy we're all connected in this
energy but the fact is energies are
Communications
and we vibrate and broadcast just like a
radio we're broadcasting who we are out
into the field and we alter what's going
on it is beyond language it's a
communication it has nothing to do with
words it's an energy that's available if
you just want to feel it and I think
that's the big issue feelings because
feelings are telling you you feel good
yes I'm having more energy you feel bad
you feel weak I'm having less energy I
say why is it relevant it's more
powerful than words
energy can tell me am I with people that
are supporting me because I feel good
around them or do I have a little quasi
feeling of this it doesn't feel right to
me so we have a new world that we're
coming into and it's based on the energy
and if you can read energy
you are being guided if you can't read
energy you don't know what's going to
happen next if you follow the words
that's where we have been sold a bill of
goods where people say yeah these are
good words what do you think and then
I'll buy that because the words and I
say yeah but if you ever stop long
enough to say how do you feel about it
not how what you hear about it it
empowers you beyond anything in the
world so the wake-up call now is yeah
listen to people fine but feel feel that
people feel where you are feel is this
what I want to do do I want to do this
or I want to do that I say you can ask
your head and rationalize anything but I
say don't ask the question in your head
ask the question of your heart
your heart is the monitor of the
vibration your heart will give you an
answer more accurate about anything in
your world than your rational thinking
will when a raindrop hits a pond
the ripples that come off of the
raindrop
or the shape of water
but the water was shaped by the energy
from The Rock
so the energy is now visualized not the
not the Ripple itself it's the shape of
the Ripple so we have all these waves
and I go so what and I say well when you
look at a pond and it's raining out the
first thing you notice that all the
ripples are converging with each other
and they're modifying each other and
that so basically everything is
connected and everything is energy but
the final shape is really dependent on
the the waves and their patterns when
they come together
some energy comes together and it
enhances power that's called construct
of interference and in human in human
terms that is good vibes yeah mainly
because urine energy pattern and if
you're in an energy field that is in
harmony with you two energies and
Harmony come together and they have they
add up
so that we get more power okay so there
are fields that are really good and you
can feel them Good Vibes and as I said
how what's Good Vibes I feel more power
being around you not that I'm touching
you or anything at that level because
you're rating radiating energy I'm
radiating energy but if we're radiating
harmonic energy we're in musical terms
synchrony absolutely Harmony Harmony
right and that's enhancing of power but
then there's another form of energy and
this other form of energy is uh let's
say this wave is going up and this wave
is going down when this one's going down
this one's going up so they're not in
harmony okay uh and they're interfering
and it's called destructive interference
which is the opposite of when we just
said two harmonies come together they're
interfering but it's called constructive
because there's more power but two
energies can come together in a
destructive form and cancel out
everything uh and like um in technology
they have earphones that are called
noise canceling they got all this noise
you put the earphones on the noise
disappears I said what where'd the noise
going the interesting part was the
earphones have a microphone
they're recording the sound of the
environment the vibration
and then through the electronics it
plays the sound back but just out of
phase so they're not both in harmony now
one is going up and the other's going
down they're just out of phase but that
when you add up two out of phase waves
that's cancellation
to make uh you know uh those kind of
earphones for example noise canceling is
it's not you subtracted something from a
noise you added a noise to a noise you
added a vibration to a vibration so now
I say oh well now there's two there's a
range energies can come together and
enhance and multiply and be more
powerful
or energies that are not in harmony can
come together and cancel each other out
okay constructive interference
destructive interference but in human
terms is constructive interference Good
Vibes more power and destructive
interference bad vibes what do you mean
by being able to change inner Evolution
because we all really do believe that
genes are destiny
well the biggest story comes down to
knowledge is power and everyone goes
yeah we all knowledge is power but let
me put it in a better way for us now a
lack of knowledge is a lack of power
and a misperception by definition is a
lack of knowledge and now I have to say
we have been for the last 50 years
operating under two very uh important
misperceptions a the one you brought up
genes control our life this is totally
false uh and the second one is actually
uh the idea of a Newtonian universe
that's split into physical matter and
and visible energy in two different
Realms and they don't communicate and
whatever is physical should be you know
interfered with by something that's
physical so that's why we have
pharmaceutical drugs we have a physical
body you want to fix it you have to give
it something physical so those are the
drugs and that's an outdated and
disempowering illusion because it turns
out it's energy and Consciousness that
shape the world and and and let me just
emphasize it so it's not so it's a weird
sounding yes Consciousness our mind is
creating this well quantum physics is to
me the most valid science on the planet
being before it was fully understood the
theoretical ideas that were presented
have all been actually realized that uh
the that this is such an amazing science
quantum physics and I say so what's
relevant about this valid science I go
the first principle in quantum physics
is consciousness is creating our life
experiences and uh you know that's oh
that's so new age I go no that's about
as hardcore science as there is and uh
this Consciousness and and this is why I
love working with you Lynn because your
job has been raising Consciousness
around the world and that is how we're
going to evolve is not physically
evolved but we're going to evolve with
Consciousness and so uh the knowledge
that you're providing for people is
empowering and I like to do the same
stress hormones shut off the immune
system
okay so that's two problems right away
growth maintenance shut off by blood
vessel squeezing shut immune system
stress hormones directly inhibit the
immune system so I'm not putting energy
in to internal problem when I'm being
chased and then I I always call the
third one the insult to the injury you
just injured your body now you will know
what the insult is I told you the stress
hormones and the in the gut squeeze shut
when you're in fear that's a butterflies
in the stomach you can feel it it says
queasy queasy and I go what else the
stress hormone shut the blood vessels
off and the thinking brain back right
here the the prefrontal cortex and when
the blood is squeezed the blood vessels
are squeezed out here the blood is
pushed to the hind brain that's where
reflexes occur and reactions occur no
thinking
so guess what
under stress you shut down thinking and
now you're just reacting and I go so
you've lost the power of your
Consciousness it's not working the
subconscious mind is one million times
more powerful and works 95 percent of
Time Versus the small conscious mind
working five percent I said that's the
one that's stressed that's the one
that's struggling it says I want
something and I'm not getting it and I'm
going to make it and I go you're trying
to change the world when your own
behavior was the one that was sabotaging
it and that's because you didn't see
your programs and like Bill you engage
these programs and you don't even know
you have these programs but then as I
said well if you want to see your
programs your life 95 coming from the
program your life is a printout of your
programs
the things you like as I said they come
in they came in because you have a
program to acknowledge them but if you
understand the things you struggle over
are not because the outside is
preventing you from getting there it was
your own invisible 95 of the day playing
programs you didn't even know you had
and that's where the sabotage comes from
and yet we want to blame and fix
everybody on the outside and think that
we're just a recipients of all this
without recognizing we're the creator of
all this and that sounds like oh so new
agey and I go listen quantum physics is
the most valid science on this planet
and principle number one quantum physics
Consciousness is creating our life
experiences you want to change your life
you don't change the world
you change your own Consciousness the
world changes after that whatever you're
waiting for be a peace of mind
contentment Health it will surely come
but only when you're ready to receive it
with openness and gratitude
of all the characteristics needed for
both a happy and morally decent life
none surpasses gratitude happiness and
health are the just rewards for living
and gratitude
wow I remember the first time I read
that I doubted that gratitude could give
me health and happiness but now I know
differently
[Applause]
Igor Igor house how sweet of you to
remember my
party later
ah yes another year would be wonderful
ah
well you know what
that whole story that Ben Franklin told
us about gratitude and health well it
actually works and now scientifically we
know why because built into every one of
ourselves is the Fountain of Youth
well what's the Fountain of Youth in the
cell well it's something called
telomeres telomeres they are special
parts of the DNA
so when you open up the nucleus of the
cell the chromosomes come out in their
46 chromosomes 23 from your mother and
23 from your father but what is a
chromosome well what it is is a sleeve
of protein wrapped around a double helix
of DNA
and the significance about this is the
telomeres as you can see in this picture
of an X and Y chromosome stained red are
the telomeres at the ends of the
chromosome through the ends of the DNA
are I say so what is the telomere it's
extensions of DNA after the genes
meaning it's a part of the DNA that
doesn't program anything it's just
extended DNA happiness and gratitude now
that's the big one happiness and
gratitude means you love your life so
much that you want more so unconsciously
you will activate the enzyme to increase
and enhance your life this is also
associated with a positive outlook
because if you have a positive outlook
that means you're looking toward a
future and again feedback says then
we're going to have to activate this
enzyme to have that future and the last
two aspects that enhance the enzyme and
give you long life are very important
and that is again having that self-love
appreciating yourself which means I'm
enjoying and appreciating my life
experience and when you're in love that
of course drives you to stay around even
longer and that will activate the enzyme
and lastly and most importantly is being
in service meaning you have something to
do and what the feedback of the system
is says I can't and now I have to be
here longer I have something to do and
so being in service is one of the most
important things to extend your
telomeres and keep you around and in
conclusion the information about
telomeres and telomerase is very
important because they represent the
equivalent of a fountain of youth in
every cell and between your mind and
your cells the biology of belief reveals
how your Consciousness and your thoughts
can extend your telomeres by activating
telomerase when you appreciate life when
you have gratitude and when you're
looking for love and happiness on the
planet you can extend your life so
interesting you're very powerful to
change your life and make it one of
happiness joy and health for a long long
time I need to empower the people
because they have been invisibly
disempowered without the knowledge that
their life is coming from programs that
they didn't even put in there
and these programs really support what
you want so you play the programs and
all you find is you're not getting what
you want those programs never gave it to
you
you know a famous book uh Kiyosaki wrote
a book called Rich Dad Poor Dad this is
truth here it is simple truth if you
grew up in a rich family you were
programmed how to be rich and how to
have money if you grew up in a poor
family you were programmed to recognize
you don't have any money and you don't
have any power and I say then a rich
person will stay Rich why because 95
percent of their life is coming from the
programs they downloaded from the rich
parents who made all the money the poor
person that's going to stay poor because
95 of their program comes from the
poverty mentality that their family
experienced when they were young
and all of a sudden it says well then
you've got programmed you want to be a
rich kid or a poor kid I said well what
the hell is your program right
and the big one that we're talking about
David is the program of fear because
we've all been programmed with some
Vision that other people have told us
about the afterlife the fear the hell
the damnation oh I don't wanna die I go
hey from what are called near-death
experiences where people have died for a
period of time
almost every one of them says the exact
same thing
it was better out there than it was back
here again and you know because a lot of
them when having this experience or
given a choice do you want to stay here
in the afterlife or you want to go back
and most of them would prefer to have
stayed there but have obligations and
came back right but the point was yeah
you're not this physical body you're the
broadcaster the energy but when you're
playing through this body venue or the
experiences of your life at this point
when you're out of body you are the
energy and the energy is forever people
don't realize the power program here
I'll give you one right now cancer is
one of the leading cause of death in in
the world right now and I go but what I
go there's no Gene that causes cancer
well oh they're oncogenes we call these
cancer genes like the breast cancer Gene
I go those are genes associated with the
cancer they don't cause the cancer
for you know example so many women live
in fear of the breast cancer Gene
because so many haven't but they live
what's the fear I'm gonna get the cancer
I have the Gene and I said that fear is
a vision which is manifesting into their
reality but then I go you know fifty
percent of the women that carry the gene
never get the cancer I said what's the
point the point is this possession of
the gene didn't cause cancer
it was a lifestyle that was undermining
your biology that activated expression
of these genes
the gene didn't activate itself so all
of a sudden it says oh my goodness then
the idea of cancer didn't come from the
genes I go no it came from the
programming programming of disharmony
dysfunction not living in life the fears
that are programmed because our
Consciousness is creating this world oh
that's quantum physics oh yeah that's
epigenetics oh yeah that's absolutely
right that's Placebo I go what do you
mean
I'm sick and the doctor says it's the
greatest newest research pill ever it's
gonna cure you you take the pill you get
better and you go wow yeah that was
great and then you find out the pill was
a sugar pill there's a very important
point
and what the hell heals you right the
conscious belief
that you would be healed manifested
healing
and everybody oh yeah Placebo my
thoughts manifested my reality go that's
exactly what it's all about and yet oh
Well we are in a discussion of placebo
what people don't discuss which is much
more important to understand is well
positive thinking can heal us negative
thinking is equally powerful in
controlling the character of our lives
so that negative thinking can cause any
disease even death if you just believe
you're going to die you can die just
from the belief of it wow looking at the
world and seeing what's going on right
now all the chaos the upheaval that's
going on is so distressing at one level
and it's interesting for me because as a
scientist I can stand up and talk about
the fact that today's chaos is a
necessary requirement for the evolution
that we would love to see and yet I like
you have to live in this crazy world
it's mind-blowing it's crazy and it
becomes really important because all of
this stuff that we're hearing is
motivating fear and fear by its
definition is disempowering because when
you're in fear you're expressing I have
no power to take care of myself and we
give up power and we give it up to other
people to create the world for us and
obviously by looking at this computer
and watching what's going on around the
world those so-called leaders are not
really helping us get to the destination
of a heaven on Earth reality
and it's time to recognize yes fear
takes away our power I've talked about
that in many many lectures talked about
the fact that stress hormones actually
shut down our Consciousness and puts us
into a reactive mode
well this is not a time for reaction
this is a time for creation
and this is what the emphasis of quantum
physics has been telling us that our
Consciousness that is making creation
and yet if we're living in fear and
Consciousness is coming from Fear then
what world are we creating well that's
the chaos we observe every day on the
news so in this situation what we really
have to do is just listen to the words
of Franklin D Roosevelt when he said
the only thing we have to fear is fear
itself
also relevant today are the profound
words by Frank Herbert in Dune where he
says fear is the mind killer and this is
what we have to recognize well I've been
talking about the fact that
Consciousness is created in a world and
I say it's based on science well let me
give you a very important fact it was in
1927 in the founding of the science of
quantum physics that we get the most
important Insight from one of the
founding fathers of quantum physics Max
Planck and what does Max say all matter
originates and exists only by virtue of
a force we must assume behind that Force
the existence of a conscious and
intelligent mind
he concludes this mind
is the Matrix of all matter
well that was what 70 some more years
ago 100 years ago I say has that changed
I go no look at this for example this is
an article out of the most prestigious
scientific journal on this planet nature
and I say what's this article I said
it's called the mental Universe it's by
a Quantum physicist at Johns Hopkins
University I'm not going to go and
describe by everything he says in the
article because Richard Khan Henry the
author summed it up in the last sentence
let me emphasize for you that last
sentence in this article in quantum
physics
the universe is IMM material
it's mental and spiritual an interesting
thing about the Matrix is that we're
given a choice to take either a red pill
or a blue pill taking the red pill wakes
us up and the blue pill puts us back to
sleep those that have taken to Red Pill
believe they really have awakened but
the fact is this biologically speaking
how do you know whether you're really
awake or whether you're still asleep the
whole point about this is when you're
asleep and you're in a dream you don't
know whether you're awake or in a dream
they all seemed exactly the same some
people like to consider the Matrix as
nothing more than a science fiction film
but in truth it's actually a documentary
we've all been programmed and 95 percent
of our life is coming from the program
we are not living the life that we
desire because we have been programmed
but what is the real nature of taking
the pills in the first place as we've
described before we came here to make a
choice do we take the red pill or do we
take the blue pill as the Oracle says
how can I make a choice if you didn't
come here to make the choice you've
already made it
you're here to try to understand why you
made it whether you take the red pill or
you take the blue pill that's no choice
at all because that choice is taking the
pill either one but it's a taking
situation and the problem with this is
civilization has been taking for
thousands of years taking and taking
from where from Mother Earth nature
taking her resources and using them to
the extent that there are no more
resources from Mother Earth we're facing
a problem now as being takers we as
being takers have created what is called
the six mass extinction of Life on this
planet we have taken so much from nature
that nature is collapsing the real
choice is what is the opposite of taking
and that is giving and this is what
nature is calling upon us to do right
now stop taking from nature and let's
give Back To Nature because this is the
only way we can create balance and
Harmony in our world nature is the
source and it is time for us right now
to return to that Source through this
chaos nature is teaching us how to learn
to live in harmony with each other as
well as learning to live in harmony with
nature itself this is the point of
cooperation to come here and create and
maintain that balance of Harmony and
peace humankind has been programmed with
the delusion main limiting beliefs that
you just hear consistently that most
people tend to have if they're not in a
have a a higher level program that
they've caught and switched with well
one of the main beliefs that they're
caught up in is the lack of power they
feel over their own health and their own
reality then I'm a victim I'm a victim
of my genes I'm a victim of this world
out here I say if you if the belief
system is translated into Behavior if I
believe I'm a victim then my behavior
will be as a victim no power you guys
tell me what to do and I'll try and do
what you just said and I say well that's
the biggest problem of all because
quantum physics I mentioned is the most
valid science and principle number one
is you're the creator of this and it's
like well when are you going to own that
and the answer is I could say it but
then you walk away and a few minutes
later you're back into your world again
everything is gone you know listen it
took me a while I learned and understood
that oh my God this is how it works and
I was so excited I wanted to get people
I'm going to tell anybody to listen to
this experience this is how it works so
a beginning got some people together and
I started to go up let me tell you how
to create the most beautiful life
experience and then they'd look at me
and go you know Lipton for a guy who
says you know this your life doesn't
look that good interesting it was my
wake-up call that said how the hell can
I talk about how wonderful this is and
I'm not practicing it and I immediately
said to myself
no don't go out there and talk to
anybody about this why until you do it
nature so what were they what were the
things that were holding you back
before you've discovered this and then
what was the new program that you
started to implement for yourself on a
consistent basis to have a hundred
percent upgraded program yeah well uh
one of the things professionally okay I
was doing a great job I I had a great
professorship in a medical school all
that kind of stuff you know personally
my life sucked really put a relationship
off the ground I go why not I go well
now that I know about it I was
programmed about relationships by
observing my father and my mother
well they had dysfunctional
relationships so what do you think I
downloaded dysfunction so my conscious
mind goes forward and says yeah I want
to have a great relationship I get into
it my subconscious mind steps up and
says oh this is how we do a relationship
you oh oh
game over you know why because I didn't
see the negative behaviors that I was
putting out my partner potential partner
saw them and gave them calls for alarm I
don't think I want to be with this guy
you know that was me and then I realized
that and that's when I really had to go
in first thing and start to change who
am I and I'll tell you the biggest
problem
uh now after years of working
people do not love themselves
um
and I say what does that mean I said if
you have a program where you don't love
yourself then rationally logically
can anybody else love you and the answer
is no
because you don't think you're lovable
that's right and somebody says you are
that oh I love you and then you go well
you know you probably don't have any
quality control I know I'm not lovable
what's wrong with you you know and then
at some point you push them away and
then they're not there then you go
I'm not lovable nobody's here I push
them away you know and I changed that I
was nearly what 45 years old 40 some
years old and I had zero quality
relationships for all that life right to
change the program
and within a couple of years I I'm now
with my partner Margaret and and the
fact is she was involved with a workshop
training program for people so she
understood processing and stuff and when
I came and we added the science and the
processing uh we've been living a
honeymoon for 26 years really years
waking up every day going wow still here
another day for fun another day for
being in love it was great and it still
is but if I didn't change the program
that would never have been part of my
life at all I would have been my whole
life struggling the fear
which is human specific
is the fear of mortality
there's no other organism that knows
it's going to die
and I say that fear
is what then we gave up our power to
have somebody assuage that fear it's
like oh it sounds so bad or whatever you
know we we bought what religion why
would we buy religion well I want to
tell you about what happens after you
die the big mystery and I say oh then
all of a sudden guess what they made the
program for my life I go who the hell
are you there's a program for my life
well I bought it because I was in fear
and fear means I have no power and when
I have no power I'm going to seek
someone who says they have the power and
then I'm going to accommodate what they
do and so people join in a religion
because they have the fear of the
afterlife well I'm going to tell you the
beautiful part about my research was I
didn't believe in spirituality okay I
had no to me afterlife was home I'm
chemicals and when I die I go back into
chemistry you know that's what it is
but when I understood this said oh my
God
I'm an immortal entity I'm a spiritual
field quantum mechanics a field
and all of a sudden I started to realize
oh my goodness I I I have no fear why
I'm not gonna die I'm not even in here
so how the hell am I going to die and
once that fear
was gone my life was radically different
I tell you why
because we all live with that biological
imperative that says I'm afraid to die
and I said but what if you're not afraid
to die what if you don't see death as an
end what if you see it's just a
transition into another way and all of a
sudden I say what the consequence of
that is no fear I said then what does
that mean I said then I'm more powerful
because it was the fear that took away
my power and if I don't have fear then
you can't scare me and I don't I'm not
scared and I don't care about your rules
about afterlife because I have my own
understanding now you don't have to try
and tell me about afterlife I know what
I am I'm a spirit I'm an energy field
how effective is your conscious mind at
overriding the subconscious I say it
works five percent of the time with a
miniature computer and I go now that's
your problem
I go the only way you can override the
program is not play the program that's
when we said stay Mindful and then we
then said well that's going to be
difficult because we have to think
so there's only one way out
no no don't keep it a secret tell
everybody there's only one way out
re-program the subconscious mind
and I go significance if you would put
wishes and desire programs into the
subconscious mind
that means that that program would be
operating 95 percent of the day meaning
whether your conscious mind is in
control saying these are my wishes and
desires or the conscious minds thinking
then the subconscious mind comes in and
said these are my wishes and desires
then guess what then 100 of your life
your living wishes and desires
and therefore all of a sudden then the
the the work has to come back to each of
us as individuals each of us got
programmed each of us is manifesting
that program we give up our power in
many of the programs the fine example is
you were sick as a kid and just like
your parents and any other family
members when you were sick you went to
the doctor
I go that's a habit I said what does it
mean it says you learned this in the
first seven years the program it says
when you're sick you give up this power
and you go to that doctor and you accept
the doctor as the power of over you
because when it came to health it's like
no no you don't do it the doctor doesn't
that's the program I say so what's the
point you have given up power over the
control of your life and have given it
to the truths quote unquote offered by
the doctor I go significance I go
the doctor misreads your diagnosis
and then tells you oh I'm sorry you only
have three months left to live
and I go significance
95 percent of the day the program says
the doctor is the you know
the correct one the true what do I know
the doctor knows what do I know so 95 of
the day then your belief system is going
to do what take the words of the doctor
and manifest them as truth
I go what's that mean well you're going
to die in about three months I go from
what I go hey that was a misdiagnosis
you're still gonna die because your
belief system will manifest in illness
that will terminate the cancer for
example is not due to any genes there's
no Gene that causes cancer
the genes are correlated with cancer and
I go what causes cancer I say disharmony
and repressed anger is one of the big
ones I go so then I say the genes didn't
cost I say no
so I said then what caused it I say my
Consciousness I say what repressed anger
you know and I go so what I say well
change Consciousness and guess what
you can go into remission
the cancer will go away as soon as you
change the Consciousness and all of a
sudden it's like I thought I was a
victim of the genes I said that's a
program
and that is totally incorrect
because as quantum physics says
Consciousness is creating our life
experiences and as the new biology which
I'm familiar with called epigenetics is
how Consciousness controls the genetics
and all of a sudden I say oh well then
biology and quantum physics now share
the same story yeah you're creating this
and the idea is that if you look at the
creation you're not happy with it don't
go out and blame the creation
because you never saw that you were
participating in a way invisible to you
that led to this expression
if you want to change it you have to
change you
and then the environment will change the
body provides us with Sensations
pain love joy happiness anger whatever
it comes from this mechanism it's a
mechanism the the eyes take in light but
they don't they don't see light back
here in the brain they say energy
vibrations
sound comes in my ears I don't hear the
sound I hear the vibrations taste that's
a vibration it's a chemical vibration it
almost says oh my God this is a
transducer it takes life experiences in
a body that gives us vision and smell
and taste and touch and pain and love
and joy and I say and this is sent back
to our source so we came here to have
life experiences and I go at that moment
of Awakening I said oh crap here's a
major difference between men and women
men are not allowed to have these
sensory experiences and I'll give you a
reason but women are so women are
sensitive they and that's a way of life
for them they're sensitive and then they
go about but men are so insensitive I go
that was a program
we were programmed to be insensitive for
a very simple reason you cannot be a
soldier if you're sensitive
you can't kill somebody if you're
sensitive so men have been knowingly
programmed to lose sensitivity so they
can be used to do those jobs like
killing somebody else
and I go oh my God then I miss the
reason for being on this planet I missed
the feeling of what is love all about
you know what are these senses of joy
and happiness I'm not allowed to
experience them as a guy because uh that
interferes with a soldier job
go I'm wasting my life and that was a
wake-up call I said well damn it go out
and taste it and touch it and feel and
smell it and do whatever you want if
it's really good do it again and if it
didn't work out so good then don't do
that one again you came here to have
these experiences why do you want to
waste your life having all the negative
fear anxiety all those problems it was a
choice
it was consciousness
but we didn't know that because we were
programmed to be victim and a victim has
no power
and as long as you believe you're a
victim then you manifest victim
and this is why I'm so uh honored to be
with you Jeff because you're
experiencing this you know this stuff
you're trying to get this message out to
the other people why to wake us all up
because we came here to manifest heaven
on Earth like Falling in Love
and I go then what about all this war
and pestilence and plague and and all
these things I go oh that's a
manifestation
and we're manifesting it
you can live in this world without even
being involved with all those things you
just have to change who you are and what
you are and what you want conscious mind
versus programs subconscious mind
and when you understand this you become
empowered and I say empowered to do what
I say create Heaven on Earth and then
people think oh you die and go to heaven
I go boy is that a big mistake because
you're going to get to the Pearly Gates
Saint Peter's going to be there and he
says well
how was your experience on Heaven he
said what do you mean he said you were
on earth right that's Heaven why that's
where you came to create what did you
create oh
I don't want to wait to the end man
my my mother remarried when she was
relatively older and she married this
guy who was I said curmudgeon guy he was
not very happy guy or anything he lived
to be like 95 96 or something he had
cancer my mother took care of him at
home the last week of his life
essentially wasn't there he was just
comatose more or less in the bed and
then two days before he died he all of a
sudden his eyes opened up it was there
and he looked at my mother and he said I
didn't have any fun
and all of a sudden I just said holy
crap he's gonna die in two days and he
woke up today he didn't have any fun I
said that's not me babe because when I
finished it's going to be that was great
let's do it again
the immune system protects you from a
threat on the inside yeah but if the
Tigers chasing you who cares about the
threat on the inside I go I got a
bacterial infection and a sabertooth
tiger chasing me I said where should I
put my energy in the hell with the
infection the tiger catches you the
infection's not a problem anymore so
very important fact profoundly everyone
listen
stress hormones specifically shut down
the immune system because the taking
care of the inside is not as important
as taking care of the whole thing
running away uh in fact stress hormones
are so good at this
that when doctors want to transplant an
organ from person a into person B the
recipient of that organ is given stress
hormones before the operation because it
reduces the function of the immune
system which would be rejecting The
graft and so you don't want the immune
system to reject the graft so you give
them stress hormones which what shuts
down the immune system I go well guess
what in today's world just watch the
news for a moment and all of a sudden
your immune system is going
yeah so that's number two so number one
stress hormone shut down growth because
feeding the viscera for its functions
not worthy of running away I need to get
the blood into the arms and legs again
to conserve energy because look the
immune system uses a lot of energy if
you've ever been sick sometimes you
don't have the energy to get out of bed
so it's like well when it's operating it
could drain you of energy yeah but if
you're being chased by a saber tooth
tiger
the hell with the immune system uh and
so you shut that down so those are two
insults to the system in other words if
I'm not under stress I'm nourishing my
body and I'm encouraging my immune
system I'm staying healthy but the
moment I'm under stress
both of those things shut down and I'm
ready to to fight or flight uh and then
I said well there's a third one I call
that adding insult to injury and the
answer about what that means is this the
brain has the forebrain where conscious
thinking is conscious thinking and the
Haim brain which is uh like habit and
reflex Behavior conscious thinking is
slow I mean imagine your car is going
out of control and spinning and I say
stay in the conscious mind it's like oh
I say yeah but the moment the car starts
to go out of control the stress hormones
go in remember I told you they squeezed
the blood vessels in the gut they
squeeze the blood vessels in the
forebrain I say why because it pushes
the blood
to the hind brain which is a million
times more powerful than the forebrain
is a machine processor I go so why is a
realm I go because the moment the car is
going out of control is oh wow turning
the wheel hitting the pedals you're
doing everything Beyond fast so fast
okay yes so when you're in a stressful
situation thinking is slow
and therefore the system doesn't want
you to be slow it needs you to go boom
react reflect right away so the blood
vessels from the same chemistry
squeezing the blood vessels down the gut
squeeze the blood vessels here push it
to the hindbrain we become less
intelligent when we're under stress
because now we're reactive and it gets
to a point that sometimes they're so
afraid that you take care of me and if
we give up we give up control to the guy
with the bigger stick yes you take care
of me well that means we're a victim
victim means we're powerless I go when
stress hormones are in the system the
only Power you have is to run and I go
and relevance about that is very is very
simple and that is that
it was only designed with saber-toothed
tigers in mind I go why is that real
they say well the Sabertooth tiger is
chasing I go yeah and I'm running like
crazy I got blood in my arms and legs I
got all the energy and I say yeah but if
you escape that tiger in a few minutes
of running
then there's no more threat
and then all of a sudden the stress
hormones are gone and then you're back
into growth and everything else
but today stress is 24 7 365 a human
body was never designed to be
maintaining a stress situation because
it suppresses the Vitality of the system
and in today's world with the idea of
covid everyone's afraid I go and guess
what the one thing you wanted was your
immune system to work and the one thing
that's not working because you're afraid
is the immune system I go the more fear
people have the sicker they become yes
and this is a wake-up call that says man
we have to stop listening to that fear
of drum they keep beating the drum every
or everybody's gonna die I don't know
I was gonna die
you know there are people who are indeed
vulnerable because they're already
stressed immune system people that live
in stress are already open to a problem
uh older people whose immune system is
are not working up to the fullest
capability they're under threat because
their immune system is already
compromised and then there's the people
with what are called comorbidities what
are they I say these are stressors on
the system that are chronic overweight
is one of the biggest ones in the
serious cases of covid 78 of those
serious patients were overweight why
overweight is a challenge to the system
and you're already challenging your
immune system before the damn virus
showed up so that's a big problem uh
Diabetes Type 2 meaning that's a stress
World diabetes is a stressor that's in
the system the more stressors that you
have going
the less effect of your immune system is
so it turns out here's a number
unfortunately Americans
UH 60 of Americans have at least one
comorbidity they're slightly compromised
okay but forty percent and this is where
the issue comes from have two or more
simultaneous comorbidities these are
people that are ripe for infection why
their immune systems are already
compromised before the damn virus showed
up so it's like well then I'm am I
afraid of coven I said well if you're a
healthy person no if you're you know if
you're a compromised person then you
should be taking care of yourself I
don't have to take care of myself you
have to take care of yourself because
you're the one that's open and yet we
want everybody to put on the mask and
everybody to get the vaccines I go
that that's
stuff I was going to say a bad word that
stuff
is not valid I go to me it's not Val I
say
the country of Gibraltar 100
of that population has been vaccinated
and guess what Delta went through there
like a plague man and I say yeah but
they were all vaccinated I go yeah
because the vaccine doesn't work I go
well yeah but now all we're Chronicle no
the vaccine doesn't work and they say
well get your booster shot I said get
the booster shot I didn't even work the
damn first time it takes a second time
at work and so the real issue is this
we have to take care of our health
uh and not wait for other people to
protect me from them if I'm a vulnerable
person it's my responsibility to take
care of my health mind controls not just
what genes are being activated but mine
can alter the blueprint I can make 3 000
different proteins from the same
blueprint just based on how I see the
world so all of a sudden it says wow we
are very powerful We're The Architects
and we can create Health we can also
create disease because we're the creator
of it okay so now comes the the big part
and that is this
to me the most valid science on this
planet is quantum physics quantum
physics I say that because uh back in
1927 when it was theoretical they came
up with a whole bunch of things you know
Albert Einstein Max Planck Heisenberg
they came up with a theory of how
everything worked well it's nearly a
hundred years and guess what almost all
of their theories are totally accurate
so we have a deep deep understanding of
quantum physics Consciousness is
creating our life experience principle
number one it was back in 1927 Max
Planck founder one of the founders said
the mind is the Matrix of all matter
that's where the movie The Matrix comes
from do you see value in going backwards
in other words in Psychotherapy or in
going back to the past no why wouldn't I
why didn't I say value in that and I
said because when you go back and Replay
that problem
you've exercised that problem again you
have pushed the buttons that created the
problem in the first place that's why
they have so many boxes of tissues in
the in the psych office because you're
going to cry your eyes out why because
you're going to be replaying the trauma
of what caused the problem and this is
the cool part
it no longer exists it's not there
anymore except for you carrying it with
you there's a point where I say well
then why should I go back and repeat
this because it's just going to cause a
replay of the same program which
reinforces that program I go I don't
care about the past I care about here I
am today I want to go this way what do I
want today I don't care about what
happened back there not that I should
forget about it because I don't want to
replay it again but it doesn't control
me anymore because I say replaying that
is just the you know putting a in the
old days they had records you guys don't
know about but they had knee record and
if you keep the needle gets deeper in
the group like we don't want to play it
again so it's irrelevant to go back I
like it there's a story of a two
Buddhist monks and monks are not the the
male monks are not allowed to touch
women and these two monks are walking
along the path and they come to a river
and there's a woman women all dressed up
in her wedding finery and she's crying
and crying and it's what's wrong she
says well I can't get across the water
and you know I'll ruin my clothes and so
one month just picture up
walks across drops her on the other side
and then the two monks walk down the
street about half hour 45 minutes later
the one that didn't pick her up turns to
him he said you picked up a woman back
there
and then the other monk says I put her
down 45 minutes ago you're still
carrying her
and if you get the story the story is
this
it was over
the history is over do I want to repeat
it no so there's a way of seeing what it
was but I don't have to repeat it
because I have to say what is it I want
not what is it I don't want a lot of
people I don't want this I go yeah but
what is it you want
people have more problems answering what
it is they want than saying what they
don't want and the important part about
this is you can only move into the
future that you want by acknowledging
what you want not saying I don't want
that anymore I said well that didn't
that didn't give you your future uh and
and so yes there are ways to reprogram
the subconscious uh and when you do your
life will change in permanently so many
people think when you die you go to a
place called Heaven I go you didn't
understand we were born into heaven this
is where we came to create this is where
we came to experience if you lose the
body and go out there you have
Consciousness that's really great I'm
not saying it's not but here's the
opportunity to what to manifest make
something do something experience
something if you then decide I'm going
to do it metaphor metaverse I go well
then you wasted all these beautiful
receptors that were designed to to have
those wonderful experiences to manifest
them for real more powerful they can do
more at least heaven and yeah for most
people to tell I go is it hell because
you can't you know because it's the bad
place I say no it's hell because your
program that you got took away your
creativity
and programmed you to be the victim in a
world that you're actually creating so
as a victim you can create a world of
being a victim
and the idea is yeah but if you're a
master then you can create the world of
being a master you are a great example
of it yeah I I you did driving then you
created uh the wine and then you had the
Cosmetics or the candles and all that
other you know that all that stuff you
you took your mind and took it out and
made creativity what is heaven that's
what it's one what is Heaven is a is a
definition of what you want I said do
you have to die to get what you want to
say no matter of fact it's easier to get
what you want when you're alive because
this is where you can do it so the big
joke is everyone's thinking oh when I
die I'm going to go to heaven and I'm
going Jesus your whole missed the
experience man it was here is where you
created are you creating Heaven are you
creating hell that was a creation
and the idea is if you own it
like you've done like I've done like the
people that you've interviewed on your
program
they have taken over ownership of their
creation
and they're creating the life that they
want and most other people are saying oh
this is against me and my genes aren't
good and this world and that and I'm a
victim and I go
sorry folks you missed the opportunity
to create next time you come back you'll
figure it out maybe as you understand
the terms quantum physics and quantum
mechanics or Newtonian physics and
Newtonian mechanics what you see is that
physics and mechanics are synonyms so
physics really means the mechanisms by
which the universe operates and the new
physics quantum physics was something
that I really wasn't into nor were any
of my colleagues in the medical school
we were all trained in Newtonian physics
and the difference between the two is
very profound Newtonian physics says the
world that we live in the universe we
live in is a machine made out of
mechanical Parts if you want to
understand how it works take it apart
study the pieces change the pieces
change the operation That's the basis of
medicine we look at a human body it's a
machine made out of physical parts when
it's not working right change the parts
by buying chemicals and drugs and that's
the way that conventional medicine
operates when I started to read the
quantum physics I realized oh my
goodness the the whole foundation of the
universe is not based on a mechanical
physical Universe it's based on the
invisible energy called the field so
let's say if I hold a magnet right here
in front of you and you can see the
magnet but what you can see is the
invisible magnetic field and so what it
says is well we are physical things in
our world like physical bodies we're
immersed in fields electro magnetic
fields magnetic fields itself all kinds
of fields like telephone cell phone
Fields television Fields radio Fields
whole ranges
what is the difference between the
Newtonian physics and the quantum
physics is this Newtonian physics focus
on the particles quantum physics says
you want to understand why the particles
take this shape then you have to
understand the field it's the field that
controls biology it's the invisible
forces there's a great quote by Albert
Einstein and it's simple it goes the
field is the sole governing agency of
the particle
in other words in the world of invisible
things fields and particles matter
it's the field that gives shape to the
matter and this is the basis of quantum
physics this becomes relevant it says
okay here's the physical particles of my
body why are they in a healthy state or
why could they be in a sick State that's
the physical expression the answer is
well to understand that don't look at
the body you have to understand the
invisible forces in the field
and it's fun because if you think about
when when of course when you were young
at some point you must have had like
iron filings and sprinkled it around a
magnet and all of a sudden you saw the
iron filings form that pattern of the
magnetic field
well quantum physics would look at this
pattern and try to explain how come all
the iron filings fell in this pattern
without recognizing that the field
exists in other words can you explain
why the iron filings have this shape if
you don't recognize the magnetic field
the answer is absolutely not what's the
nature of it the body and its cells are
like iron filings medicine is trying to
understand the nature of the body by
looking at the iron filings and quantum
physics says if you don't understand
that invisible field you cannot
understand what's happening in the body
when you think about someone who's an
artist and they're creating a musician a
chef a chef or or in love like you're in
the flow right so you're just because
you're you're thinking yeah you're not
thinking you're doing and it doesn't
mean there's not participation it just
means that you're not thinking of the
future you're kind of just what the time
and space sort of change like you lose
track of time yes that kind of stuff
yeah not thinking means not diverting to
the subconscious meaning you stay in
conscious creativity yeah about this
creativity his wishes and desires so a
chef uh is so involved with the cooking
and paying attention all the details
they're not thinking and I say well what
does that mean they're not coming from
program they're coming from creativity
okay the artist the chef uh the race car
driver yeah not thinking man uh you know
we're in it we're going I had a monk
tell me I should write a book called the
speed of Consciousness well that that's
it and the subconscious is much faster
than the conscious and that's why in
times of Emergency the conscious is too
slow to help us and that's why we jump
to it but then the problem is whatever
Behavior you're going to express while
you're in that subconscious was a
program that you had a positive or
negative well up to 60 of the programs
that you downloaded are not positive
they're disempowering programs what we
now know is the conscious mind if you
stay in the conscious mind
you have power
but if the conscious mind is thinking it
is not using its power to interfere with
the uh and act with the outer world
thinking is using the power to go to the
inner world so a thought is not outside
a thought is inside yeah but the
conscience is reading a thought so I
said what does that mean I said well the
conscience is helping me create this
world oh wait wait the moment I'm
thinking
I have to take that Consciousness
redirected not look out but redirect it
because thinking is inside so I said
well what does that mean I said well the
moment you were thinking you were not
creating your world at this moment I
said what does that mean I say if you're
driving the car and all of a sudden you
start thinking what it means is you're
not looking out the window anymore you
are now looking inside because answers
for thoughts are on the inside then you
go oh my God you stop looking out the
window the car is going to crash and
they go
cool apart or not yeah the subconscious
is autopilot so the moment Consciousness
is not paying attention
the subconscious Takes the Wheel
but now comes the problem the
subconscious is not you it's the program
so if I got bad driving instructions
then when the subconscious takes the
wheel as autopilot it's going to take me
down the road to ruin it's not going to
take me to where conscious says I want
to have this wonderful success but my
program is you're not worthy you're not
smart enough you're not deserving so
when that program grabs the wheel it's
not going to take me to success it's
going to take me to where the program
goes so if I disempower you in your
programming and 95 percent of your life
comes from that
the rest of your life is struggle and
it's not because you couldn't create it
it's just you didn't realize that this
subconscious guy is working 95 percent
of the time and you don't see it and
this is where how come life seems to be
a struggle from the outside coming in
when it's like oh my God you didn't get
it you're creating both success and
you're creating failure it's not coming
from outside when people gather together
and have thoughts like a meditation on
healing or peace and love that when they
come together they can influence the
world around them in fact even the
project called the global coherence
project revealed that when people come
together and start sharing awareness it
actually changes the electromagnetic
field of the earth so our thoughts are
not passive they're influencing
everything in the world in which we live
so when people come together consider
this that each person's brain is like a
tuning fork sending out thoughts and
vibration and this is revealed in the
sign science of Magneto and cephalograph
most people are familiar with something
called the electroencephalograph you put
wires on a person's head and you could
read their brain activity but a new
understanding of how to read brain
activity magnetoencephalograph the probe
is out here
this is the most profound insight for
this reason if I can read your brain
activity out here that means your brain
activity is not contained in your head
it's broadcast into the field so each of
us our brains are like tuning fork
sending out vibrations to the world each
individual has a power to their tuning
fork but as more and more individuals
come together it's an additive effect
that you have more individuals more
power and the more individuals the more
power and so as we come together in a
group
our thoughts are really being Amplified
and sending out a vibration and these
vibrations affect people who are not
even listening really because the power
of amplitude of these thoughts will
entrain people who are not even paying
attention because of this power so a
person just walking through a field will
go feels it because we're all
broadcasting this energy and this is why
coming together in a community and
sharing awareness has power a very
simple point if I go outside with my
tuning fork right now and say Let There
Be Peace in the world I'm not
necessarily going to change anything
maybe not even anything right here in
the street
but if we get large number of people to
have the same thought would change the
world and this is why it's so important
to understand the collective nature of
Consciousness that when we all start to
have Harmony we broadcast that Harmony
and the world will become in harmony
with our thoughts it's time for us to
wake up and recognize that there's a
program being played out here we're in a
darwinian program because everyone
accepts that as oh that's the science
even though darwinian theory is wrong
because this revolution isn't on
competition evolution is cooperation
that's the new insight that changes the
game of struggle into harmony when we
start to recognize we all have been
programmed with a belief that uh if
you're not out there fighting somebody's
going to walk all over you and you lose
so you better go out there and and
struggle and win and fight and all that
and I Go Again a garden is not a
Battleground it's the height of
cooperation and Harmony and what we have
to do is let go and the idea is the more
you invest in the existing program the
more Consciousness you feed that
existing program The More You broadcast
the pattern of that existing program and
the only way out is stop does that mean
I don't read the news well actually I
don't read it I just read the damn
headlines and that's enough for me to go
okay I don't I don't want to be there I
live in a different world no I'm in the
same world as you know but I live in a
different world why well sometimes we
have to recognize maybe it's time to
take your power back maybe it's time to
take your job back and do something that
is more in harmony with your life I mean
I was a tenured professor in a medical
school but when I realized I I was
teaching incorrect information at Gene's
control life which is totally false uh I
I said no I I can't tell you this
anymore
and uh and the Beautiful part about it
is guess what I'm living this most
wonderful life and I go how did I do
that I said I had to let go of the
programs that I knew I was engaged in
that didn't offer Vitality Life Energy
love if they didn't offer then get the
hell off of it because it sucks your
energy energy is life I talk about
what's called the energy checkbook and I
go what's that I go you have a bank
account that's the money in there is
your life I go yeah it is I go you just
don't write checks for nothing hey oh
Lynn what a beautiful blue sweater you
have here let me give you twenty dollars
that was really nice you know you don't
do something like that and I say we have
been giving away our energy
so much with no return coming back I go
what do you mean I said well you you get
into some like a political argument uh
between people and they go oh heated
oven
and they use all this energy and I said
and after the argument what changed
nothing
I said then what the heck energy is life
you just gave away your energy you're
losing life and that's when all of a
sudden I realized
invest your energy into things that
either enhance your Vitality or the
Vitality of the world in which we're
living because those are places to Build
a Better World to invest your energy in
the negative things and all that kind of
stuff like that you're building a bad
world with that and you're using your
own energy your life gets shortened and
so the reality is consciousness is real
it's a currency and if you use it and
spend it appropriately you can have a
much better life negative beliefs are
equally powerful in controlling your
health as are positive beliefs except in
the opposite direction a positive belief
can heal you from any disease a negative
belief can kill you
by creating any disease a belief can
create the disease as much as belief can
create the healing and I guess the
significance of this is profound because
nobody talks about the negative belief I
go negative beliefs are powerful it's
called nocebo as you mentioned and as I
said they can cause any disease and they
can kill you just because you believe
you're going to die you can die
just from the belief it's as much as you
are dying of a cancer you change your
belief and you can then heal the cancer
I go how I love this because a friend of
mine her name is Anita morejarning and
she wrote a book called dying to be me
she had four years of cancer and the
final days of her life
in the final week she was so emaciated
that the cancer lumps were sticking out
of her skin because she lost so much
body weight and the cancer notes are
sticking out
she's on a machine for life support
she goes into a coma in her oncologist
who's been working with cancer patients
for years says oh this is the final
stage of a person before they die
so get in touch with all the family
members and say Anita is dying she's in
a coma this is a sign that's the end of
her life
and she has an out of body experience of
Consciousness change that the issues
that were related to her life had to do
with a lot of
um the fact that uh she was so feeling
guilty of upsetting her family she came
from an Indian family with pre-arranged
marriages and she pulled out of a
pre-arranged marriage about three days
before the wedding which made her family
look like you know
people it's like you broke a
pre-arranged marriage that's like
against the rules and everything that
irritated her father who she was she had
a lot of love but then that irritated
her father and then she felt she's now
alienated from that love
that's what precipitated the cancer
her out of Body Experience on the last
day of her life according to her
oncologist uh she had an out about
experience of communicating with her
dead father who said no you know what
happened on that what happened on Earth
stays on earth when you transcend you're
not there anymore and everything's
wonderful and we love you and all that
she comes out of the coma
and the first thing she says I want to
eat something you know she was like give
me some ice cream and she was like what
you know
within a day she was off the machines
within two within a week to two weeks
there was no visible cancer anymore and
in fact the doctors were saying it's in
there somewhere and she kept saying no
there's no more cancer
and they kept looking after a couple
more weeks of looking they said no she
doesn't have any sign of cancer she was
on her last day of life with cancer
and a belief change
that she realized her father is not
angry with her she didn't alienate the
love of her family and and that thought
when she woke up out of the coma was the
placebo in a sense of the healing
thought that healed her from her last
day of life so people with cancer and
they're all struggling I go even to the
very last day the moment you change that
Consciousness is the moment you can have
the cancer go into remission and
disappear killing the cancer cells is
like oh I'm going to get those evil
cells and I said the cells were just
following the instructions that came
from your Consciousness you don't want
evil cells then change the evil thoughts
coming from your Consciousness the
cancer disappears so it's a power that
we have it's a power of our creativity
which we don't believe in and I go okay
quantum physics is the most valid
truthful science in the sense that the
theoretical understanding of
quantrophysics matches every experiment
that has been understood about it I go
so I go well let me tell you the first
principle of quantum physics
that principle is
Consciousness is creating our life
experiences
you want to change your life experiences
don't change the world
change the Consciousness the world will
change behind that people have heard of
the phrase use it or lose it and
frequently they're referring to oh well
I can build up my muscles through
exercise and I'm using them but if I
stop using my muscles then
disappear and I go use it or lose it
applies to every system in the human
body every system is based on use or
lose it and most importantly the
creative aspect of a child is when they
were in child development that's what
kids do they they create ideas they play
and through play they are being very
creative but if we are doing what we're
doing now and that is programming them
with uh STEM Science technology
engineering math uh I say those courses
are not creative those courses are rote
memorization can you memorize the
equation can you memorize this and I go
if what has happened is our education
has taken the creative part out because
of finances oh yeah uh years ago when I
went to school we had Great Courses we
we you know we had shop for the you know
for the guys or everybody want to learn
how to fix and make things you know uh
home Mech uh we had music we had art do
these were programs and most of those
have been sacrificed in budgetary
reasons to provide more stem and I say
then what have you thrown out of the
education I said the creative part of a
child's education has now been
transferred to the rote memorization of
science technology and engineering and I
say and the result is this
we are not as creative as a population
uh not that long ago well okay well it
is long ago because I'm old but uh the
the US was the leader in technology we
because we had the best education system
that provided creativity for the kids to
you know to move into the future today
the US is somewhere near the bottom of
Western countries in regard to
technology why we've lost our creative
character uh use it or lose it we've
lost it and this is a wake-up call
giving children back the exercises of
creativity because that's what engages
those brain cells and if you don't
engage those brain cells then they don't
develop and use it or lose it applies
the most important thing about
transcending a program as I mentioned
before is identifying what the program
is and that's why I wanted to give
people an insight to their own
programming by just reviewing their life
and recognizing things you like come in
because you have a program things you
desire that don't don't come in is
because you have a program that doesn't
support that and I say well how do you
change these programs uh and I said
there's three fundamental ways to change
a program and it's very critical because
the subconscious mind is a habit mind
the conscious mind is a creative mind I
go what's the difference I say habit by
definition doesn't want to change I mean
if a habit changes then it's not a habit
anymore so I say first issue is this the
programs that we were downloaded with
are habits they were put into our mind
before age seven and then we just play
them like a push the button play the
program push the button play the program
now not all habits are bad a matter of
fact you wouldn't like it without a
subconscious I'll give the example when
did you learn how to walk you learned
how to walk before you were two you
could be 102. you're still walking I go
why that habit is there and it doesn't
change then so the first thing we have
to recognize habits are not like open
hey just change me you actually have
have to like push a record button to get
into that habit I go well how do you get
a habit I said well how did we get a
habit in our life I said for the first
seven years we were in a state of
consciousness called Theta which is
hypnosis and we downloaded it uh and the
relevance about that is uh Theta is a
lower vibration than conscious which is
Alpha and focus Consciousness Beta And I
go so why is it relevant because when we
are working like right now we're in beta
High Focus Consciousness School room
kind of working like that but when we go
home and relax the vibration slows down
that's called Alpha so we're in a calmer
consciousness
but what people have to recognize is
this the moment you close your eyes like
I'm just going to sleep Consciousness
switch went off I'm not in an alpha I
just dropped into Theta I go well
Consciousness is closed but Theta is
hypnosis so if you put earphones on and
you go to bed uh and you put the
earphones on and there's a program
playing through those earphones of
things that you want to be true in your
life uh you might hear some of the
program while you're still awake but the
moment Consciousness disconnects you're
in a zone of theta before you go to the
lowest vibration Delta which is absolute
sleep so every night there's a window of
opportunity putting earphones on as soon
as your conscious mind goes to sleep the
subconscious mind is going to take
whatever's coming in those earphones and
begin to download them because that is
hypnosis so that's self-hypnosis but
that by age seven changes because by age
seven now we spend more time in
Consciousness than in Theta uh and I go
but we still learn things you learn how
to drive a car you learn how to practice
with an instrument you learn all these
things I say why is it relevant in the
answers simply this how did you create a
habit practice you practiced it so the
second way of changing a program is
practice a new life if you don't like
the one you have uh yeah I like a new
age of people fake it till you make it I
go yeah what does that mean I said well
I'm a miserable person I want to be
happy so I said but you're not happy I
said yeah but fake it what does that
mean I say all day long anytime you can
just consciously pass by you say oh I am
happy I am happy you could be miserable
I don't really care the idea is I am
happy I am happy repetition practice is
how you make habits and so if you keep
saying all day long I'm happy I'm happy
and you say it for a period of time
because it's habit practice there's a
day you wake up and you already started
happy because the program is already in
there you don't even have to do it
anymore less than one listen less than
one percent of disease is connected to
genes I go where the hell is all the
disease coming from
90 Plus
of disease
is stress
and and all of a sudden oh so I said
well you can relieve all the take all
the cancer cells out I say did you get
rid of the stress no oh well then guess
what it's coming back
because that the the cells didn't cause
the problem they are a symptom of a
problem
and it's all diseases like
cardiovascular disease 90 has nothing to
do with genes you're not living in
harmony you're living in fear a lot of
it has a fear is the greatest cause of
stress because fear means I'm powerless
that's what fear means oh my God
something's coming I I'm a victim I am
powerless somebody help me and then the
pharmaceutical company comes and goes
we're here to help you I go another line
of BS wave says
pharmaceutical company isn't here to
help you it's a company it's a
corporation I say give me the rule
number one rule in law when you make a
corporation what is the number one rule
in the corporation's leadership and the
answer is your job is to make a profit
for the shareholder that's number one if
a corporation is not making a profit for
the shareholder then it falls apart
doesn't work anymore so I said well how
do you make a profit for the shareholder
I say gotta make a lot of money I go
well making a lot of money does that
mean you're going to help a lot of
people I go well tell them we'll help
them we'll sell them with drugs and
they'll buy the drugs and then we're
going to make a lot of money I say do
the drugs really work I go how many
people are out there because the doctor
said your blood pressure is high or your
cholesterol level is high and we're
going to have to give you statins statin
drugs I go how long do I do I have to
take a prescription of satin drugs and
then the doctor goes how long do you
want to live oh you want to live then
take stat and drugged your whole life I
go
I can't take my whole life I said are
they gonna help me now comes the truth
statin drugs only helped three out of
100 people
97 people out of 100 have no positive
effect from certain drugs in fact over
20 of those people will have side
effects that are disastrous so wait I
took the statin drugs to help me with my
cholesterol level three people are going
to be helped 20 people are going to get
sicker I go well maybe we shouldn't sell
the statin drugs they go are you kidding
me man that's a prescription for life
that means we have a customer for a life
and I go nobody paid attention to the
side effects being more dangerous than
the the healing effect I go people don't
care because they're told whatever the
advertisement told them drug companies
they don't give a damn why because the
97 people that Deb no positive effect
from satins are going to pay them every
day of their life to take a satin drug I
said is it going to help them I go nope
but they're going to pay for it every
day and the drug company's like yay
I could sell lots of Silent drugs and
you know what they did to sell more
drugs because there was a cholesterol
level and it said if you're above this
cholesterol level you need a Statin drug
like then what'd they do they kept
changing the cholesterol level over time
it was no no you have to have less
cholesterol oh all of a sudden it said
people that you know had a certain level
of cholesterol below the required part
no I don't have to take statin drugs
then I said no no you need a cholesterol
down here oh now that many more people
are going to take statin drugs every
time they lowered the amount of
cholesterol to another level there's a
whole new cohort of people that are
going to buy the Statin drug because oh
it used to be oh that cholesterol level
was okay now it's not okay now you've
got to take the drug because they kept
lowering the level and every time they
lower the level there's a million new
customers for statin drugs did it help
absolutely not the side effects were far
greaters like five seven times greater
side effects than healing the
subconscious mind is yours not shared by
anybody else so it's not a common mind
for for civilization it's what you down
downloaded what you learned and how
you're you know playing in your life
your conscious mind though that's the
one that is coming from the field uh
where everyone else is involved and so
Consciousness is what connects us all
subconscious is your life experiences
it's used for this lifetime uh and
something as the new science revealed to
me which I didn't really know for most
of my life is that uh We Are Spiritual
entities I I was teaching genes you know
and now I start to recognize from the
physics that we Are Spiritual entities
uh and that uh the body is like a
television set my spirit is the
broadcast where when the television
works you say television is dead and I
go yeah television is dead but is the
broadcast still there and the answer of
course it's still there and I said yes
this is the same thing with the human we
are not in this body we are received
leaving a broadcaster field in terms of
the science of quantum physics there's a
field that's playing through us and I go
so if your body dies the field didn't
die it's still there it's like that blew
my mind because I said oh my God you
can't die you're not even in here and
then the The Joy about that was you also
come back again when another embryo has
the same set of what are called
self-receptors that are reading that
field for you each of us has our own set
of these self-receptors These are
proteins no two people have the same
sense so each of us is receiving a
different energy broadcast then let's
just turn it back for a second to the
subconscious mind the subconscious mind
is learned in this lifetime from the
experiences we have in this lifetime but
when you pass on and go back to the
field subconscious is gone and when you
come back again guess what fresh
subconscious and you start all over
again so the subconscious is used now
for this life the conscious is always
here it's in whether you're in this body
or not in this body and that is the
Perpetual person that you really are I
want peace on the earth and all the rest
of fighting all over the place that
means nothing
but if I get enough people
to say we want peace on Earth and we get
to that number and as Lynn said it
didn't start with a massive number
started with a small number but that
number grew why buckminister Fuller
singer says Build a Better World people
will come from that world to visit your
world and what Lynn is showing we can
build a better world and why is it
increasing a number of people because
people are saying I want what Linz has
it always reminds me of the movie
the restaurant
at a table watching her goes I want what
she has well this is what Lynn and Brian
offer
they have something to say they have
something I want what she has why
because it's empowering why
it changes your Consciousness your
Consciousness is creating
if the creation doesn't look good you
don't change the world you change the
Consciousness the world then changes
because of your creativity and that's
why
um Lin's work to me is so important to
get people to wake up and say miracles
happen when you get enough tuning Forks
together and how many well apparently
eight tuning Forks is good to change
cells in your body are not connected to
the outer environment but they have to
adjust themselves to that outer
environment and the relevance about that
well then how they know what to do
because
something has to tell them what the heck
is going on and so it turns out the
nervous system
interfaces the environment and then
sends signals to the cells to tell them
what's going on so the cells are
responding to the perceptions and
actions of the central nervous system I
say why is that relevant because I say
it's an interpretation and so the cells
the simple point you got 50 trillion
citizens and the conscious the mind is a
government yes and the government talks
to these cells now you can have a bad
leader who tells them this is all crap
it's all falling apart things don't work
and it's like they're not going to be
happy cells and it can profoundly
different you talk to yourselves and
tell them okay everything's cool we're
great
when there's a big you know in the U.S
an accident or you know big big problem
in some Community the president goes to
the community yes why does the president
go because it takes the attention of all
the other citizens of the of the states
focuses on the intention where that
president is so if there's an area where
there's a disaster the energy of all the
people are addressed to that area
because the president shows up there and
that's the leader so I'm saying the same
thing for yourselves you're sort of that
president in there and the point is when
you touch some part on your body your
conscious attention focuses on that part
of the body and intention is energy and
it's a healing energy when you're
sending a good message uh to that part
of advice so you touch it talk to it and
it sounds like oh crazy I go no you are
directly sending information via your
Consciousness to all the cells to focus
healing on this part if you change the
picture in your mind you change the
chemistry you change the Fate so I'll
give an example
if I have a picture of Love in My Mind
the brain releases complementary
chemistry dopamine pleasure oxytocin
bond with your loved one growth hormone
which does exactly what it says it
enhances your growth and that's why when
people fall in love the chemistry of the
brain going into the blood the culture
medium enhances Vitality people glow
when they fall in love people are
healthy when they fall in love it's not
an accident it's the chemistry of your
culture medium but now I say but wait
what if I have a picture of fear I go oh
well love chemistry doesn't come out
when fear is in the picture the brain
releases stress hormones and factors
that affect the immune system and growth
of the system and I go oh my goodness I
say why is it relevant changing my
thought changes my chemistry the
chemistry adjusts my biology so if I can
control my thoughts I can control the
chemistry and therefore I control the
biology that takes me to empowerment
Mastery after being programmed by
medicine and biology all these years
that you're just a victim of your genes
that's 100 false genes cannot turn on
and off by themselves they're controlled
by the signals of the environment which
are then controlled by the brain and the
Consciousness and all of a sudden it
says yeah but I control those things I
go yes you do and as a result you have
power
to to heal yourself and create what you
want on this planet in today's world I
love the phrase because it is funny but
it's true
fake it until you make it man you want
to be happy well do you have to
habituate happy you have to say every
day no matter if you don't if you're not
happy I don't really care you have to
tell yourself I am happy I am happy you
have to repeat it ah habituation
repetition why I'm consciously repeating
it every day and look at my life my life
really sucks oh Bruce I am happy I am
I'm saying that I go well why are you
saying it because repetition is how the
subconscious mind learns I say why is
this relevant and here's the fun part
because after I've repeated it a number
of times the subconscious says okay I am
happy as I've learned this I go why is
it relative that 95 of the day the
subconscious function is to make that
program real if my program is I am happy
the function of the mind is to make sure
I'm happy if the if the program says I'm
going to get cancer because I heard that
from somebody else then the function of
the mind is to make sure I get cancer
because that's the belief I'm work
working with
and if if it says I am a victim and I
can't get out of this
then the function of the mind is yep
look you see you I'm showing you you're
a victim and you can't get out of it
because I'm running a show you're a
victim how did you learn anything after
age seven and the answer was repetition
that's what it was it was just
practicing the more you repeat something
the more it becomes just so easy you
don't know how to play an instrument you
practice like crazy at some point you
practice so much you pick up the
instrument no consciousness of the
details of how you're playing it it's so
automatic at this point it's like
driving the car
when you first got in the cars like oh
my God you've got to watch the window
the mirrors the gauges the engine sound
every yeah it's like so much today
you've been driving a car a long time
guess what you don't even think about it
but the key in you're thinking about
where you're going and all of a sudden I
saw the more you practice the less
effort it takes to carry out whatever it
was you were practicing now the question
is what are you practicing something
positive or something negative because
they're both become programs whichever
one you're practicing if I have a
picture of fear in my mind I'm afraid of
something my brain translates fear with
different chemicals stress hormones
cortisol norepinephrine uh factors that
affect the immune system that are called
cytokines or histamine so basically in a
state of conscious fear the brain
releases chemistry that complements fear
that chemistry goes into the body's
blood and that changes the behavior and
the genetics of the person
so it means there's a difference between
having positive thoughts and having
negative thoughts and people say oh that
positive thinking doesn't really work
but that's not true the best example of
positive thinking in a scientific study
is called Placebo you have a disease and
doctor says here's his new pill and it's
the brand new science and it's going to
cure you and you believe it
and you take the pill and you get well
then you find out the pill was a sugar
pill so then you're left with so what
made me well it's not the sugar pill it
was the positive belief in that sugar
pill and how it's going to help your
life so that's called Placebo positive
thinking positive result unfortunately
most people don't recognize a more
important point negative thinking is
equally powerful but it works in the
opposite direction
so it turns out for example less than 10
percent of cancer is even connected to a
family lineage ninety percent of cancer
just comes out of the blue so to speak
but the reality is no it's a result of
stress and negative thinking so it's
important Point positive thinking
negative thinking equally powerful
because that's the level of
Consciousness that is translated into
the chemistry that controls your
genetics I just want to add a very
important point to this quantum physics
is the most valid science on this planet
there is no science that has been tested
more and verified more I guess so what's
irrelevant because the primary principle
in quantum physics is consciousness is
creating our life experiences and well
when you add epigenetics to that physics
now we understand the mechanism of how
Consciousness is controlling our biology
so biology and physics are coming
together to reveal that we are very
powerful creators of Our Lives I am so
grateful to offer this because as each
one of us takes back our power and each
one of us actually starts to live heaven
on Earth like you did when you fell in
love even if it was only for a week if
you could do that every day of your life
and everyone around you is doing that
every day of your life then the simple
truth is this and Earth does become
Heaven if we're all living as if it's
Heaven and the function is to create the
minds is to take that vision and man
manifest it if I believe I'm living in
heaven then my world experience will be
what would it be like if I lived in
heaven and being in love is the one time
you unconsciously unknowingly
took back power the equivalent of the
record you unknowingly became powerful
and I said yeah in 24 hours you changed
your whole demeanor of life after you
met this person yeah I go
you could have done it in different ways
didn't have to be with a person you
didn't need to fall in love with a
person you could fall in love with uh
gardening yeah if you're a gardener you
go out in the garden and you're digging
the garden you're having so much fun and
the plants are growing and everything I
go you just manifested heaven on Earth
for you it's not beautiful living in the
garden I go well it doesn't have to be
another person the life doesn't love Is
Just focusing on something you desire
a pet a garden artwork cleaning up the
garage
yeah because when I'm doing it I'm
creating order and happiness and all
that and I go well fine then you're
cleaning up the garage I'll go to clean
up the damn garage so if you're cleaning
up because wow that's so much better now
I feel so much better in here it's so
clean I know where everything is I go
being in love doesn't have it could be
anything that keeps your conscious mind
in front because it's when you conscious
mind goes in the back is when you become
the product of your subconscious program
so
um and this is great and the hardest
part about programming that people don't
recognize is you have to make all
programs present tense positive
statements not future statements I will
have I shall have you know something
like that say no I am it is and the
reason is it's logically simple not as
this uh let's say I'm not well I say I
want to be well I say fine let's record
that oh now let's come back a whole year
later and push the button it says I want
to be well I said well it's been a whole
year you never got there you just wanted
to be well for a whole year that's what
the program said so if you are sick and
you write I am healthy and the mind
looks at the program says oh I got to
change this it doesn't change the
program it brings health back so that
the body matches the program and so that
that's the whole issue about it the
function of the mind is to take the
program and manifest it and if you go to
a negative program then obviously
whatever manifests is going to be
negative please listen to this
a negative thought is equally powerful
in controlling the biology
who as much as a positive thought can
heal you a negative thought can kill you
it can make any disease you can have a
negative thought about cancer and
manifest cancer you have no no genes
that are even cancer related genes and
it's like where the hell did it come
from you are creating your biology as a
complement to what you see
so if you see a positive world then
you're getting Positive Vibes coming in
and it feels really great and if you
live in a negative world or one you
believe to be negative then the cells
are inside cowering going oh my God it's
not safe out there and and so my cells
are just adjusting to my perception so
changing your perception is like well
where's that and I go that's your mind
just to begin with a very interesting
concept that
um
judeo-christianity has provided the
large population of the world with a
belief
that Genesis occurred and God created
the planet and the water and then the
animals and the plants and after all
this creation then God said let's add
some humans to the mix so we didn't come
from that creation we were added to the
Earth
science comes in and also separates us
from the planet because conventional
science based on what is called
Newtonian physics we are physical
particles separate from each other no
we're all separate pieces and we lost
the understanding that the word Gaia
is a living organism the Earth is a cell
we are connected to everything we've
lost that Vision we feel that we are at
peace in a in a bunch of pieces and as I
said are we going to be safe or are we
going to be afraid in this and I said
then we want to protect ourselves and if
you understand the breathing of most
people it's very shallow it's right up
here why I don't want to take too much
of the outside in I'm protecting myself
but as sad Visa said we we still need
oxygen so we breathe in a little bit of
oxygen but we want to be separate
and the simple reality is
those beliefs are totally false we were
created with everything we are created
from everything there is no separation
between us and the world in which we
live
and so when we are breathing very
shallow we are actually remember I said
protection close yourself down shallow
breathing closing yourself down when you
start to learn to take in the breath of
life you are opening yourself to the
entire world around us
and that opening of the world makes us
part of this world not A Separate Peace
from one another
so breathing becomes a very important
part of am I hiding from the World by
just breathing a little tiny bit or can
I take in this breath and become part of
this Oneness that we are your separation
is where all the problems of life come
from
your breathing can open you up
to this entire world to take it in you
are this world you are every bit of this
you're a reflection of everything out
there you came from that
so basically can we stop the protection
that we think is helping us but it's the
protection that is killing us
and breathing can I take this in
can I take the world in yes
and I can Thrive and so when we start to
let go of that protection the breathing
will start to go from shallow chest to
abdominal because I'm taking in the
world with every breath I'm taking in
the energy of the world with every
breath and that is what makes us whole
you have shallow breathing you have fear
all of a sudden you cannot be whole
anymore
and so we come here to learn to take
power back
and and oh my God Closing word yoga the
most profound teachers I ever sat before
to have the opportunity to learn the
lessons that were so magnificent that I
can't fully put them into words
and who were those teachers
they were the cells that I was working
on in a Petri dish they showed me from
my point of view and my reference to
life that there was something called
spirituality that I didn't know existed
and The Moment I Saw the mechanics of
how a signal
from the universe comes in to my
body suit my virtual reality suit and
was running this there was this instant
of recognition I said oh my God I can't
die
I'm not even in here
that's concept of immortality was one of
the
first and most important lessons I had
why because all of us when we grew up as
children there was a point of learning
that people die
and that you are people and that you
will do so yourself and your parents
will die and your friends and loved ones
will also die
and we get so caught up in that the
moment of reality that I couldn't die
was the most uplifting experience I
could ever imagine because the fear
that we are programmed with that you may
not say every day oh I'm afraid of dying
you don't have to say it it's built into
your subconscious it's running your life
every movement you make every action you
take there's something in your mind that
says how's this going to affect my life
am I going to threaten My Life by doing
this there's another person going to
threaten my life and we get into that
so for me the truest knowledge I got was
not a Devotion to Spirit it was an
owning of spirit it was owning it
without saying I think it's this way I
owned it
and the moment I owned it a weight that
I ever knew I was even carrying around
disappeared because I became free for
the first time to recognize I'm here for
something other than my life
the cells taught me this as well and the
cells also taught me what I mentioned
briefly the other day the next important
factor when you put the two together
and that is
that we have been programmed
in this world
not to love ourselves we've been
programmed to be criticized we have
parents who criticize us we have
teachers who criticize us we have people
all around that criticize us so what
does that mean every action you take
there's something back there the program
of critical criticism that says are you
doing it right are you doing it right
and then you live by this criticism
when you learn
that you're part of spirit as real
and you realize you're a part of
everything that is you're a part of if
you want to say God God how can you be
critical of God
and all of a sudden I started to realize
I cannot lead my life
in that critical nature I'm gonna own
who I am
I'm a spirit that has come to this
planet to experience and to create and
to manifest Heaven on Earth and I have
now two lives I have previous learning
life struggle anger control trying to
fix everything and I have post
experience a calmness an understanding
that it's all driven by love even if
other people can't see through their
filter of criticism you're still driven
by love every one of you is a piece of
all that is every one of you
and if that critical mind comes up and
says not good enough in any sense
there's a point where you have to stand
back and say that's not me I am more
than the program
and when you let go
of that problem of self-criticism
you learn an experience for the first
time in your life self-love
and why is this important because as I
learned through years
I could not love
the people around me until I can learn
to love myself
it was always simple it was a joke in my
head somebody to say they love me and I
go
what kind of quality control do these
people have I can't love me how can they
love me
and I would reject and push away the
love because I couldn't own it to accept
it and if I could leave one message
behind about love is that you are love
you are a piece of God that came here to
create the most beautiful thing in the
universe planet Earth
as we go outside and see nature and the
glory of this planet that's why we can
understand how beings from other places
or if anything jealous not to come here
to share in this beauty
so if I could just leave you with this
understanding you came here to create
Heaven other people took away your power
by programming you to criticize yourself
own Who You Are
because then your creative abilities
will come forth and guess what I found
out I didn't have to go out and make it
happen I didn't have to go out and beat
the world to find success to bring it in
I just walked out in love and it all
came to me just like every one of you
here is a part of that one love and when
I come to uplift which is the whole
message to tell people we are one love I
get so elevated I was behind the
curtains back there when we are made out
of love was reverberating through this
building and you could feel it you could
feel it even if I couldn't see you I was
behind a curtain I could feel the power
of that love because you were all so
beautiful without your filter
and so recognizing that was a choice
there's a choice to say do I want to be
the filter or do I want to be me
and when you start to recognize me as
not just this isolated thing but me as
every one of you joining together is one
Collective all that is
the glory of Life on this planet cannot
be built by anything else in the
universe than what you can do here you
are creators
own your creativity own your spirit it's
not words it's not devotion
it's a true knowledge You Are Spiritual
and that is the opening of life there's
a lot of people that have doubts about
the concept of the influence of global
meditation and rightfully so because
we've always been programmed to ignore
the invisible realm as not being
relevant to our world but now with an
understanding of quantum physics and the
role that the invisible realm is more
powerful in shaping the Physical Realm
then is the Physical Realm itself it
really adds emphasis to the character
that the energy fields in which we live
are actually shaping the world that we
experience
this is just a made-up idea that I just
said the answer is no there are
scientific studies that have shown how
meditation and groups have changed
characteristics of cities or towns in
regard to violence or love or what was
going on in the city so basically said
while meditators were in the practice of
their meditation and bringing peace to
the city it actually changed the people
in the city according to the statistics
Point did it work and answers absolutely
unfortunately when the meditators went
home the whole thing stopped point is
very simple
if we live with that spiritual activism
in our heart and use it every day then
this is not just an on and off event
this is a continuous process of shaping
the environment and the community in
which we live it's been a very strange
year on this planet chaos is happening
all over the place and we're looking at
this going on what's going on with our
world it seems like it's turning upside
down the answer is it is turning upside
down now that might be the bad news for
most people but it's actually for my
insight it represents the good news how
could it be the good news that the world
is so filled with chaos and the answer
is simply this is that human behavior
has precipitated the six mass extinction
of Life on this planet which includes us
five times in a history life was
thriving on this planet in some event
like accommodating the Earth upended the
entire ecosystem wiping out up to 90
percent of life
this is the sixth mass extinction and
the source of this is much closer to
home than a comet because the source of
our Extinction is human behavior we are
undermining the web of life and as a
result there is a collapse of nature
going on all around us if we don't
change we're going to go extinct I'm not
talking A Thousand Years folks I'm
talking decades from now
so what you're seeing is a collapse of a
foundation civilization is changing so
rapidly covet has pushed it super fast
with all of things are changing with the
covet the way we work on the world and
we commute on the world things like that
are profoundly different now and we're
moving into a different way of life we
are not going back to the old way of
life we are creating a new version so
when you look at the world falling apart
Don't Be Afraid actually be very joyous
why if it doesn't fall apart Extinction
is right here in a few decades if it
falls apart it gives us an opportunity
to create something better to move from
here to there frequently a mass every
day how come you look so happy and the
answer is I wake up happy and why do I
get this happiness where is it coming
from and the answer is this it's another
day on planet Earth and what's so
exciting about it is it's another day
that I have no idea what's going to
happen but the greatest wishes and
desires for some fun and excitement and
a very joyous life so I start off with
today's going to be a great day and
almost every day it ends up being a
great day doesn't mean everything works
right but the beautiful part about it is
I've really learned not to carry
anything forward that is not really
happy and in joyous in my life it
reminds me of a story two Buddhist monks
are walking along and Buddhism monks are
not allowed to touch women at all and
these two Buddhist months are walking
along they come to a river and not that
River there's a woman dressed in her
wedding Refinery and she's crying and
she's crying because she can't get
across the river wearing these clothes
so one of the monks just picks her up
carries her across drops her off on the
other side then the two monks continue
walking
and about an hour and a half down the
road one monk says to the other one how
could you pick up a woman
and the one who picked up the woman
looked at him and said I I dropped her
off an hour and a half ago why are you
still carrying her and the whole idea
about that is the meaning of it is when
events happen in our life it's not
necessary to keep carrying them
especially if they're negative ones you
can just stop right there and go on to
the next thing it's a choice do I want
to be in an environment where I'm not
happy or to want to be in an environment
where I am happy oh Choice well
obviously but most of us have that
choice but are so caught up in
conventional rules and conventional way
of mannerisms and social structure that
we hold ourselves in places we don't
even want to be and then we sit there in
our mind getting aggravated by the whole
factors I don't even want to be here and
I go well the guess what choice
pick a place you want to be go to the
movie go do something else
break the pattern
and when you break the pattern is your
moment of power because when the pattern
is broken there's new choices at that
moment but if you don't break the
pattern you're going to follow a Litany
of up or down depending how you started
off the process the litany down not a
great trip I'll tell you that but hey I
think it's over 20 some years I haven't
been depressed I haven't even been angry
I get upset by some things of course but
it doesn't mean I hold them I drop that
person off on the other side of the
river and stop carrying it
and this is the choice it really is a
choice you have to think about it
because it's a conscious Awakening at a
moment that gives you a choice that
wakes up and goes do I want to do this
and that's that moment of choice you
take that moment of choice and then you
say I'm moving into where I want to go
you make a habit out of this because you
repeat this and then guess what you
don't even have to think about it
anymore because the subconscious program
will always redirect you to the place
you want to be and the whole other world
that we used to experience I used to
irritate us and aggravate us and all
that anxiety stuff
it just doesn't exist and it doesn't
mean everything's going right but the
whole beautiful part about it is well if
it doesn't go right okay stop now let's
go do something else because it's the
idea it didn't go right and then why
didn't go right and who didn't make it
right and where is it going to go now
and blah blah blah and what are you
doing you're digging a hole and it's not
going up it's going down
and the whole idea is choice but the
most important part of choices you have
to stop long enough not get caught up in
in the in the program and play out the
program there's a moment while you're
playing the program maybe you can
separate and look at yourself and say
why am I doing this because that is the
moment of power that is the moment where
you can say I have a choice I can do
something totally different than to Stew
in this stuff
then you are a powerful person and in
today's world we're told don't go by the
feelings if I did I would have probably
been better off at this moment so when
we recognize we have to make a decision
we can do it in two fundamental ways
first do an assessment an analysis of
step by step what does this decision
mean and why should I choose it but when
you get to the end before you absolutely
take that information and make a
decision based on that ask your heart
and the reason why is this the heart
doesn't care about the individual steps
in the decision the heart only looks at
the conclusion either you get more
energy from this decision a good vibe a
feeling that this is right or the heart
will give you a feeling of bad vibes
less energy a feeling that maybe this
isn't the right answer so the
significance is really profound because
the heart just reads energy and higher
energy is more life less energy is less
slide so in making a decision yes it's
acceptable to do the analysis but before
you come to that final decision please
check in with your heart feel the
feelings if the feelings are good that
means go toward that direction but if
you feel questioned about it if you feel
weaker about it doesn't just feel right
the heart is telling you right off that
that energy is not good for you and you
should use some other decision oh wow
that's so wonderful what a wonderful way
to make a decision based on these
feelings and they can help us find the
direction that we need to go in and lead
us to a better life
foreign
I guess that's not really working for me
at this moment
whoops
oh well
computer and simulation
[Music]
Scotty how many times have I told you
not to leave me off and see you know I
can't swim
meet me at the bridge you have some
explaining to do patience for a simple
reason
you have to have patience in
reprogramming because you're dealing
with habits that will automatically
replay themselves every time you're
trying to rewrite a habit so you have to
create a new habit it's not going to
happen the first time or the second time
but as you become aware and conscious of
it every time a negative behavior shows
up and you are becoming more conscious
you are in the power position of
changing that behavior at that moment
and then engaging in behaviors that you
really want
therefore not only does it take patience
but it takes practice so you and your
partner in a relationship have to have
the dialogue with each other when a
behavior shows up that one of the
individuals is is creating and unaware
of then the other person must say look
you perhaps didn't see what you just
said or what you just did automatic
subconscious Behavior it wasn't really
the best thing and through a nice
dialogue and through practice what you
can end up is again leading to an
opportunity to engage with each other
and as a result create new programming
that supports both your wishes and
desires and aspirations and this is the
next and last step of putting that
honeymoon relationship back together
so in conclusion what can we say about
this whole honeymoon effect is this
number one people talk about mind-body
interactions and mind controlling life
and while a lot of people say my mind
wouldn't have created this life
you can go back to a point where you
fell in love and recognize a very simple
truth what you created was not an
accident it was an activation of your
conscious wishes desires and aspirations
you already did create heaven on Earth
the issue is what happened to it and I
said ah the interference from the
subconscious mind if you understand the
programming and how that programming is
the default behavior and you understand
how you can rewrite that programming
then you're given an opportunity to
eliminate the negative programs in your
subconscious that have been sabotaging
you and instead replace them with
behaviors that correspond with your
wishes and desires and when you do that
so that your conscious mind and your
subconscious mind have the same program
then guess what
at that moment whether you're paying
attention or whether you're not paying
attention you'll be engaged in the
honeymoon experience it never has to go
away The Honeymooners experience that
you could have your whole life this is
why we were here we were here to create
heaven on Earth the one time you did it
is when you fell in love
it could have stayed that way if you
understood the mechanisms we have
described here
but when you do understand the
mechanisms it says you can go back and
recreate that and make it a permanent
way of life you were born into heaven
you've experienced it once or more and
you can do it again and again and again
because that's how powerful you are you
are a Creator and you are in heaven when
you use your creation you will manifest
Heaven every day in your life and enjoy
the beauty of a living experience on
this wonderful Planet the honeymoon
effect the brain is like a tuning fork
the brain works by electrical vibration
it doesn't see things you know my eyes
are sending in information no it doesn't
see light it sees vibration sound
vibration smell vibration so the brain
is a receiver vibration but now as we
know using what is called
magnetoencephalograph which is like
electroencephalography EEG yeah EEG I
put my wires on my head and I'm
recording brain activity I'm not I'm not
recording visual I'm recording
vibrations so we say oh inside the brain
there's a lot of electrical activity
vibrations which are turned into meaning
okay yeah but the new device is called
magnetoencephalograph not EEG m-e-g okay
I said what's relevant I say there's a
probe it's reading brain activity you
know what it doesn't touch the head the
probe is out here yeah I've heard you
talk about that well this becomes very
critical because basically if I'm
reading my brain function out here my
brain function is vibration yeah and
what am I reading vibration then it says
not only is my brain taking in vibration
yeah but my brain is sending out
vibration now the immediately we just
talked about construct of and
destructive interference so if a
negative vibration is coming into my
world
my brain using destructive vibrational
frequencies can cancel the negative
around me if something wonderful is
coming into my brain my brain can take
that vibration and and put it in Harmony
and then enhance the power of that
vibration yeah so the the brain has an
opportunity to cancel or enhance any
vibration in the field sorry so that
that vibration that the brain is putting
out would you translate that to the
sound of your thoughts absolutely
vibration is sound is just a different
octave but it's all sound every but
first of all I mean the hardest part
that people you know it's very difficult
for them and it was even difficult for
me even reading the book on quantum
physics is there is nothing that's
physical everything is energy and
vibration and that's very difficult for
the average person like I was to say I'm
looking at you and I said what a
beautiful physical expression and then
to find out there was no physical
expression and now it's like what the
heck does that mean and the fact is that
we read vibration yeah and so everything
is vibration in the universe and that's
the bottom line of quantum physics
humans have morality
we're supposed to anyway you know don't
kill things okay uh we're supposed to
have morality
but corporations have no morality they
just have a mission how much money can I
make that is the mission by law of what
a corporation is so I say then that's
why they can do anything let's destroy
the environment if we can make enough
money
and all of a sudden you start to see the
leadership of this world is not really
caring about what the individuals want
they want to appease the money making
part and then the laws come down and and
if it conflicts with a corporate law
then screw the people let's give the
corporation their due and that's once we
gave up and we said humans are like uh
corporations are like humans and have
the power of a human I go no they don't
they have no morality they're nothing
like a human at all uh and uh and we
gave them all the power and this is a
wake-up call for all of us that said
who's caring for you
you know I love it they always talk
about the friendly Banker
when's the banker friendly the banker is
friendly when you have money yeah if you
don't have money Bankers not so friendly
anymore it doesn't care about you at all
you know and I go same thing
pharmaceutical company you got money
we're working with you yeah I don't care
about you if you have no money and we
lost and so the evolution we're facing
right now says we have been driven to
this by a Minds that have no uh care for
an environment hey take what you want do
what you want throw crap into the water
you know all this kind of stuff dig out
the natural resources every it's like
what's our future if you do this the
answer is it's already happening
Extinction we're not in harmony with
each other obviously and we're not in
harmony with nature
and I say well that you got two choices
here
follow the money
or follow the Harmony
and right now unfortunately this is a
tug of war and corporates are winning
because fear because once you're afraid
you give up power fear is a definition
I'm not I'm afraid and I go then who's
going to help you who's got the biggest
stick yeah who's the one with the
biggest clown let's give them the power
and I'll wait here for them to fix it
and I go
they're clubbing you over that at this
point and we have to wake up I'm sorry I
went on a tirade a little bit an adult
has all different ranges of vibrations
of brain function but when a child is
born for the first two years it has a
very low vibration called Delta and a
child is in Delta well adults when
they're in Delta that's called sleeping
well yeah for the first year and a half
or two of a child's life they spend most
of their time in Delta so that's a
predominant vibration of a child's brain
but around two years of age the
vibration of a child's brain increases
at a higher level of vibration and this
level is called Theta well Theta that's
characterized by imagination and that's
true a child between the ages of two and
seven is mixing the real world and the
imaginary world at the same time so for
example the child is on a broom
pretending it's a horse well to that
child that broom is a horse so if the
mother says give me the Broom the child
looks at her like what are you talking
about because a child really experiences
that as a broom oh on the old famous tea
party where they pour nothing into the
cup and they drink nothing and they go
that was the best tea I ever had well
mixing imagination in the real world is
what happens between ages two and seven
when a child is experiencing Theta
by time the child reaches seven the
vibration goes a little bit higher and
we call that vibration Alpha and Alpha
is calm Consciousness well that's the
child's life in the beginning of
Consciousness very peaceful and loving
but then around age 12 the vibration
goes up even higher now it's called beta
vibration well beta vibration is the
brain activity when a child is in school
or when an adult is working
and the Beautiful part about this is
every year of the child's life the
vibrations get greater and greater and
then when we're adults we have the whole
range yes at night when we're sleeping
it's Delta and just in the morning
before we wake up call Twilight reverie
the brain kicks into a higher vibration
Theta and then as the alarm clock goes
off and we're ready to wake up the brain
is now an alpha calm Consciousness for
the morning and then on the way to work
the vibration even gets higher now it's
called beta and at work all day long
that's a very high functioning
Consciousness beta you know the
interesting part though is when you come
back home it goes back in Reverse so you
come home from work and you've been
working all day you're in beta and then
when you get home you start to calm down
and relax and the vibration slows down
the alpha calm conscious business and
then guess what the moment you fall
asleep and your eyes close the brain is
now in a lower vibration Theta and then
as you go a little deeper guess what
Delta and you're in sleep and every day
this Cycle Works Delta Theta Alpha Beta
coming home beta Alpha Theta Delta
cycling and cycling well this is really
a very interesting aspect of brain
function for this reason
Theta the brain activity between two and
seven years old for a child is not just
imagination Theta is hypnosis
and this is how a child can download so
much information as a little kid under
seven years of age when we understand
the nature of the progression of our
brain vibration it then becomes
important for parents to know this for a
very important reason when does a child
start to actually downloading Behavior
well very interesting fact even before
the child is born and the last trimester
of pregnancy the brain is already
beginning to hit on Theta and when it's
doing that the child is experiencing
with the mother's experience so a happy
mother is sending happy information to
the baby as programs but a mother who is
afraid frightened not sure of the world
she's living in sends kind of scary
messages to that feed it says it's
developing and the child is actually
beginning to download these messages the
mother is Head Start program she's the
one that sees the world and her
interpretation of the world is
translated into programs into the baby
even before it's born and why should
they be able to download So Much
Information well think about it this way
how many rules must a child learn to be
a functional member of a family and then
how many more rules must that child
learn to be a functional member of the
community thousands of rules if you
think about it for example how a father
talks to his own child is different than
how the father talks to the neighbor's
child which is different than how the
father talks to the mother which is
different than how the father talks to
the neighbor's wife and that's even
the policeman you got to learn a lot of
rules to grow up and be a functional
member of a family and community and the
idea of can you teach this to a child a
youngster that can't read they kind of
go to school no they're kids so the most
important Insight is that a child
between the age of two and seven is
observing the community so it's
important for us to all recognize that
around children we really must be
behaving at our best and highest level
because we are now programming the
future of that child the problem is this
when we grow up 95 of our life is coming
from the programs that we downloaded
starting even before we were born
through age seven and these kids when
they grow up are going to be the world
that we're moving into these kids are
our future so it really isn't coming
upon us to recognize this we should be
helping them with the best behavior we
must be on our best behavior because
they are copying our Behavior between
ages two and seven especially and
therefore if we want the future to be
better then we have to be better people
as parents as Community as family we
have to be the models that we want these
kids to be because they're watching us
they're recording us and they'll become
us less than one percent of diseases
connected to genetics over 90 percent of
illness on this planet is all due to
stress and lifestyle and I say why is it
relevant because if we understood this
and 90 of illness would disappear from
this planet is essentially
instantaneously uh so we have to make an
understanding of how do they connect
with each other okay so basically the
understanding is this
cells have to adjust their biology for
an environment so as the environment
changes cells have to change their
biology
and the significance about that as we
mentioned very briefly is that the genes
respond to the chemistry of the blood I
go
why because the chemistry of the blood
comes from the brain I go yeah but what
chemistry comes from the brain they go
it's based on the picture held in our
mind the brain translates our pictures
into complementary chemistry so for
example the if you open your eyes and
you see someone you love the brain
translates love into wonderful healthy
chemistry a dopamine for the great
pleasure oxytocin to bond with your
lover growth hormone which this function
is exactly that I go so why is the realm
I said well people fall in love they're
happy they're excited and they're
healthy because the chemistry that comes
from a picture of Love is a chemistry
that enhances the Vitality of the cells
in contrast though if I open my eyes and
I see something that's scary I say no
love chemistry is coming out of this
brain fear chemistry comes on I go what
is fear chemistry related to it is
simply related to an ancient history a
fear means we were running away from a
saber-toothed tiger back in those days
and I guess so what does Fear represent
something is chasing you something's
interfering with you something's
threatening and fear uh and stress can
come about I'll give you a simple
definition of what stresses anything
that gets in the way of your destination
whatever your destination is if
something gets in the way of that
destination it provokes stress okay and
I guess so what's relevant about this
and I say let's go back and understand
what the stress response was all about
and that was originally run away from
that saber-toothed tiger I go what do
you mean run away I go well you want to
save your life you better start running
immune's arms and legs and start running
and I go oh so in a state of fear you
want to use your arms and legs I go yeah
you know you hit them with your pancreas
you know the lion doesn't care about
that but if you run away You're Gonna
Make it and I go so here's the storyline
the arms and legs are what protect you
and I say and to use them they need
blood because blood is where energy is
okay now I'm going to give you a
statement out of a physiology book and
then explain it very simply and then
statement is this when uh when a
person's in stress the blood is
preferentially sent to the arms and legs
okay yeah when I'm in stress more blood
is going in my arms and legs I said
preferentially where was it before
I go it was in the gut I say well what's
the function of the gut
maintenance of the body fixing cleaning
repairing it takes care of Maintenance
of the body
I say I say so why is it relevant I said
if you're running from a saber-toothed
tiger uh maintenance of body is not
necessary at this moment Escape is
necessary because if you don't escape
then the body is nourishment for a tiger
so uh the issue about is this when
stress hormones are released into the
system they cause the blood vessels in
the gut to squeeze shut
I go why is that because then it pushes
the blood preferentially to the arms and
legs people feel that when those blood
vessels are squeezing like this it's
called butterflies in the stomach they
feel a little queasy I go what is that
that's the closing of the blood vessel
shunting the blood off you can feel it
okay so I say oh so being chased by a
tiger I shut down the growth and
maintenance of my body to use the energy
to run away from the tiger okay
number two the immune system uses
tremendous amount of energy I go what do
you mean I said well if you've ever
really been sick you didn't even have
the energy to get out of bed okay so if
the immune system is really engaged
you're using a lot of energy and I go
well the immune system is protecting me
from an internal threat bacterial
infection okay so now I give you this
scenario you're being chased by a
saber-toothed tiger and you have a
bacterial infection
how would you split the energy between
repairing the uh the infection or
escaping the tiger I hope everyone
understands how would the bacterial
infection why if the tiger catches you
the bacteria no longer is your problem
at that moment so uh basically then it
says this
when we are under a stress from an
outside threat uh the stress hormone
shut off the immune system to conserve
energy to escape the threat and then I
go wow what does that mean I said well
uh it doesn't you don't activate the
immune system because
um you need all the energy to run away
and I go well this is very critical for
a very important reason and I say well
why is it critical and I say well you
shut down the immune system and a matter
of fact it's the stress hormones are so
effective at shutting down the immune
system
that when a person is going to receive
an organ transplant hard lungs or
whatever they give the recipient of
those organs stress hormones before the
operation but why because it prevents
the immune system from rejecting the
foreign organ right away it inhibits the
immune system so stress hormones are
used therapeutically to shut off the
immune system so I say what's the
consequence of this I say well you shut
down the growth of Maintenance about it
and you shut down the immune system yeah
but it's hey if you escape the tiger
it's 10 minutes you know if you escape
in 10 minutes no more threat and I go
then what oh you return back into growth
again okay so I go so why is this Robin
I said well that was a long time ago
when the only stress was a damn Tiger
but today people have stressed 24 7 365
stress every day and it's dripping
stress hormones into them I say well
what's it doing I said well a couple of
things I just mentioned it's interfering
with the growth and maintenance of the
body which has to be maintained uh and I
said well what's the consequence of that
I said it's a breakdown of the system so
prolonged stress causes a breakdown of
the of the system okay number two it
inhibits the immune system so you're
more open to infections and threats from
the outside so now not only have I
weakened myself now I've made myself
more open for infection because immune
system isn't working and then I'm going
to add the last one because I called the
last one adding the insult to the injury
well you just injured yourself you're
not maintaining your body you're not
using the immune system like oh what
else I go
when you're in a fight-or-flight
situation thinking is not a good thing I
go what do you mean thinking is slow
it's a very slow process I go so what
happens I say when the stress hormones
come into the into the body they also
squeeze the blood vessels shut in the
forebrain Consciousness I said so why
would it do that I say because it pushes
the blood to the hind brain where reflex
and reactions are taken care of so let's
say you're driving a car and it starts
to go out of control guess what you're
not thinking the instantly your
Consciousness is shut off you're just
reflexively with a wheel and the brakes
the pedals whatever you know no thinking
I go oh
so then when we're under stress we are
less intelligent I go yes
and I go why is that relevant because
the fears that are in this world are
always compromising us to the extent
that the health care crisis is global
everywhere okay the amount of money you
spend on health care doesn't mean
anything is better U.S spends the most
money on health care and it's got the
worst health statistics of any other
country and you know in the Progressive
West I go why is that relevant I say
money didn't make us any healthier the
problem we have is not the immune system
the problem we have is stress and if you
eliminate the stress then the immune
system everything comes back to order
again and I go so what what's the issue
I say the health care crisis today has
virtually nothing to do with genes one
percent of illness that's probably about
the most 99 obviously is coming from
other where is illness coming from and
the answer is uh stress and lifestyle
the stress is what is to to prepare you
for for a threat stress says there's
something threatening you and I say well
if I'm preparing for a stress that's
what we just mentioned I say if I'm not
threatened
I'm free to go outside and do anything I
want if I feel threatened I'm going to
wall myself off to protect myself put
all the goggles on the face masks and do
all that now I'm going to be inside here
and I go you can't survive inside I'll
give a simple example when I was young
we had air raid drills in the U.S
because we thought the Russians were
going to bomb us so we built bomb
shelters so I'll give a very simple
story a city a community is in a growth
is a beautiful day out the businesses
are working the kids are in school those
Community is is growing and doing well
an air raid siren goes off what does
everybody do they stop work where do
they go they go under the ground into
the air raid shelter I say that well I
said well nothing is happening now
everything's shut down okay I go yeah
and I say then what I say well in 10 or
15 minutes all clear
we get out of the bomb shelter everybody
goes back to work so it was like a you
know half hour Interruption during the
day where we were growing then we spent
a half hour in protection and then we
came out of protection and went back to
work again everything was Pro no problem
here's the problem the air raid siren
goes off you go into the bomb shelter
and there is no all clear
I said what does that mean I said well
you can't come out of the bomb shelter I
said until what I said you can't come
out until it's all clear I said when's
it all clear so it's not getting all
clear I said how long can I live in the
bomb shelter I see not very long why how
much food did you put in there how much
water do you have in your bomb shelter
and the point is you'll use up those
resources and if you don't come out you
will die in the bomb shelter when we're
in stress we go into the bomb shelter
psychologically WE wall ourselves off
we're safe inside here and I say how
long can you survive inside the bomb
shelter I say a short period of time was
no big deal
but as you extend the time my life
becomes threatened and this covet crap
is going around and extending the fear
on and on and on again we're having a
second Spike I go
big deal I mean normal right why have it
predictable how come I have a second
Spike I said if you take the susceptible
people and you move them into a
quarantine so they're not exposed to the
virus and they're healthy in their room
and I say then you say quarantine over a
new come out I go did the virus go away
no that's still there are you still
susceptible of course you are you didn't
get any immune reaction in the bomb
shelter over there I say so what do you
think would happen if you let that group
of people you put away back out I go
they'll get infected just like their
first group of people and guess what
it's called a spike I go of course it's
a spike you took them out of the program
you put them back into the show they get
to see and then you say the second Spike
and I go did you not expect a second
Spike and what reason why would there
not be a second Spike you didn't lose
the virus you didn't gain any immune
system you know precaution against it
you just opened up the next population
yeah here we are in the second Spike of
course that's exactly what would happen
if you take the population and put it
away and then think well okay now they
can come back out I said you didn't
change anything they're just out now the
second Spike so so all of this stuff and
I go so you want to know what I believe
the biggest problem the whole thing is
because I see it as a manipulation of
information and that is this
people have power when they're in a
community
people have no power when there is no
community and the covid system broke
Community all over the world at once
everybody went to their room I go and
what power do you have I say absolutely
no power people lost all the power in
the world except for those that were
manipulating what was going on outside
of that room and that was a way of
disempowering an entire damn population
of this planet with the fear they said
go hide in your room because you can't
gather together you can't have an
opinion together no you can stay in your
room and you stay in your room and all
of a sudden oh my God that's the biggest
problem in the whole world
you've isolated people and when you've
done that you've removed their ability
to have power why does stress cause so
much disease I'll tell you why
stress you're running away from that
saber-toothed tiger whatever's
threatening you and I say what is stress
anything that gets in the way of where
you want to go is a stressor I say so
why is that relevant I go because that's
like in the mind the saber-toothed tiger
and you want to run that's what fight or
flight and I said but you use your arms
and legs I go yeah but that I need the
energy I said the blood carries the
energy so I say so what when the stress
hormones come into the body you want the
body to put the blood into the arms and
legs because you're going to have to run
that's what fear and stress is about I
guess what do you mean put isn't it in
the arms and life cycle yeah but most of
the blood is in your gut I say what's
the gut all the organs of Maintenance
take care of your health fix the blood
you know aerate clean all that stuff I
go yeah but when you're in stress I
don't need to take care of myself I got
to run away from the tiger so stress
hormones number one shut off the blood
vessels in the gut and I said that's
like butterflies in the stomach when you
feel that fear that's the stress
hormones causing the blood vessel
squeeze I said so why would you do that
because then the blood is pushed to the
arms and legs that's where most of the
energy is needed that's number one so
you compromise Health just by having
stress hormones because you're shutting
it off the maintenance but number two
the immune system uses a lot of energy
that's why when people are sick
sometimes they can't even get out of bed
I said so if I'm being chased by a
saber-tooth tiger and I got a bacterial
infection how do I want to you know
split the energy and I go hell with a
bacterial infection that saber-toothed
tiger catches you bacteria is not your
problem anymore so guess what stress
hormones by function shut down the
immune system and I go and it's so
effective that when doctors want to
transplant a foreign organ into a
recipient and they don't want the
recipient's immune system to reject the
foreign organ before they do the
transfer they give the recipient stress
hormones to shut off the immune system
so it doesn't reject the foreign organ I
say the stress hormones are so effective
at shutting it off they use it
therapeutically to shut it off and I go
why is irrelevant because our entire
world is in such stress all the time
that they're dripping stress hormones
and I say what are they doing they're
they're shutting off the growth and
maintenance of the body they're shutting
down the immune system I say net result
illness and death from stress and that
is why up to 90 of illness comes from
stress because the chemistry of of
stress redirects your energy to run not
to be conscious and aware and healthy
take care of yourself I say what do you
mean first of all take care of your
system it will manage this virus without
killing you but first of all you have to
make sure your blood has proper
nutrition you need to be healthy in a
system and our diet is so compromised
with enough food and garbage food that I
have to tell people you've got to go
back and eat natural you have to go back
and eat organic because industrial Farm
stuff is filled with chemistry that is
is causing you more problems
number two take vitamins and supplements
why especially vitamin C and vitamin D
these enhance the immune system lots of
vitamin C Way Beyond whatever you meant
Linus Pauling yes
interesting because I lectured at his uh
Institute when I was at Stanford wow and
it was interesting because the science
has revealed that massive doses I take
two grams of vitamin C every morning
high five
uh and the relevance about that is I'm
also you know I'm what am I trying to do
de-stressing I'm not stressed I live in
another world I walk out the door I
don't live in that world of the people
around me they're the ones that are
stressed I'm like I'm not stressed I'm
okay I'm 76 am I afraid because I'm old
it's oh BS belief system excuse
me uh uh that um I'm not afraid to go
outside
I I eat well I take vitamins and
supplements hey
do work exercise something to keep the
body moving because that enhances the
Vitality of the circulatory system which
is delivering immune function so eat
well vitamin supplements you exercise
and number four most important do not
put the fear in your head because the
function of the mind is to manifest
whatever you believe and if you start to
believe in the fear then the function of
the mind is to manifest that fear
and that's why the whole idea is shut
off the damn TV and don't listen to
these people because they are
disempowering you
with fear and fear is where you lost
your power because once you do fear as
you shut yourself off and you can't shut
yourself off we are connected to a world
you can't live in a bubble you'll die
and the idea is if you buy the fear you
are putting up walls around you because
you want to protect I'm protecting here
I say walls are the opposite of growth
growth you have to open yourself put
things in okay and uh and fear as you
shut everything down there's this thing
called resonance when something vibrates
at the same vibration they enhance their
power so two instruments are playing at
the same vibration that vibration is
more Amplified okay
uh but here's the point why does a
patient come to a doctor and answers
because we have been programmed to
believe that's our source of healing
they never said what the doctor had to
do when you were a kid oh you're sick we
go to the doctor remember nobody told
you what a doctor would do what did you
learn that the doctor provides whatever
it is so we give up power over our life
because that doctor is a professional
what the hell do I know I'm just as an
average person so when it comes to a
truth which is my conscious and
subconscious mind when it comes to a
truth I give up power to the doctor
so if the doctor has got a lot of energy
and everything is energy that's a whole
different I wish we had another hour I'd
talk about that but uh the illusion of
matter that that's uh that's we look
like everything is physical and quantum
physics as a scientist says no
everything is energy so I say when a
person who is an energy source goes to a
doctor who is an energy source the
healing comes from the doctor having a
higher energy a higher more powerful
energy so when I walk into the doctor's
office just walking into the doctor's
office all of a sudden I feel a
different energy because that's the
person that knows and I don't and I say
so why is a romance if a doctor goes in
not having a good day and chiropractors
know this they they can practice for
years and then sometimes they go in and
the whole day is crappy adjustments and
it's like it's not working well I say
well to forget how to do an adjustment
you've been doing it 30 years and then
no they came in with their own mind not
being in harmony whether they had a
fight with their spouse or their
financial issues I go why is it relevant
the person that came in for the healing
came in for the extra energy that the
Healer was going to give them but if the
Healer themselves have broken energy
because of the stresses and there's all
that when the patient comes in the
doctor has no powers very much and
that's why they realize geez my
adjustments didn't work and I've been
doing it all these years I go you didn't
forget how to do adjustment but when
you're touching somebody that's called
Hands-On healing
and if you're putting in energy that's
less than the energy of the patient yeah
then the energy of the patient comes
down instead of going up
the physician heal thyself meaning
before you go in there and deal with a
patient they came in for your energy and
if your energy is not up to the higher
level then you can't boost their energy
you can only boost it if your energy is
higher and so the physician the Healer
the nurse more important because they're
even the ones I'm more importantly are
the more dialogue connected to the
patient than than a lot of Physicians
who hardly even notice what's going on
but it's nurses a lot in the age that
are doing a lot of the healing why
they have the energy they spend more
entanglement time sure and and therefore
that's really interesting so what is
healing I say raising the energy the
vibration energy is life no energy death
high energy a lot of life is the
physician the Healer the nurses the
attendant are they offering more energy
than the patient has if they do then
you're lifting the health of that
patient I'll leave with this because
it's so profoundly important in our
world today and that is this apparently
presumably one of the last things Jesus
said when in the crucifixion was father
forgive them they know not what they do
and I go
we have to recognize that every human
is is a spiritual entity but also a
program
and we have to recognize that they are
not their program that's been voiced
upon them
and that somebody has a bad program and
we get into
like this I say you have to learn to
forgive them because they themselves
like Bill Bill didn't know he's behaving
like his dad they don't know it either
and so the idea is that word that that
phrase applies to each one of us to move
into the future and that is recognize
that everyone is a spiritual entity but
a lot of people have some bad programs
does that make them a bad person I go it
makes a bad program for sure do I have
to hang around with them because they
got bad program I say no but do I have
to hate them no
because they don't even know what the
hell they're doing and all of a sudden
it says this forgiveness
of people doesn't mean you have to be
with them you know they want to play
that program fine you do it over there
I'm over here but you have to recognize
is it them or their program
and then when you recognize this then
that's where the quote comes important
forgive them they don't Bill didn't know
what the hell he was doing and we are
all built
that's interesting because all the
people that are here
are in what is called Evolution yeah
everyone thinks oh Evolution takes
millions of years I go no that was the
old version because the new version
shows that Evolution builds up and then
some cataclysmic event drops it and it
builds up again another cataclysmic
event drops that these are called mass
extinctions five of them have already
occurred the last one when the dinosaurs
were here the planet was lost tropical
forest dinosaurs and everything a comet
a big one hit near Mexico
across the Web of Life to Come Undone
all the what happened 75 of all living
things disappeared including the
dinosaurs that was the last mass
extinction today we're in mass
extinction number six and scientist says
well what's causing this one and the
answer is our behavior is destroying
ourselves and the environment the
illness said this the the planet is has
got a Health crisis everywhere in other
words on the genes and it was like no
it's culture in other words when we are
able to collectively change our Behavior
we can avoid the massive the six by 16
Extinction that's the only choice we
have actually and it will work and who
will be left the ones that let go of the
old structure and said I will now put my
life energy into building a new
structure so we have I use the star
story of a caterpillar uh that turns
into a butterfly a caterpillar is a
voracious it eats everything it you put
a caterpillar on a plant eat all the
leaves off the plant then I say then
what I say well when the food runs out
it goes into a a chrysalis a pupa a
cocoon a cocoon and then comes out a
butterfly I say the butterfly has the
lightest touch doesn't even touch the
plant it's flying most of the time the
ver the caterpillar is voracious beating
up African I say human civilization is
in a caterpillar mode we are eating up
the environment we're destroying the
environment and everything like this I
say but there's a point where we have to
go into the Cocoon I say why you can't
live this way anymore I say now here's
where the issue that we just talked
about
a caterpillar comes in a butterfly comes
out I go but the cells of the
caterpillar which are like miniature
people when the caterpillar was eating
and eating it all up all the cells were
working the muscle cells the digestion
cells everybody's working all the cells
are working no more food
well there's no more digestion so what
about the digestion cells oh they lose
their job there's no more food what
about the muscle cells no we're not
moving anymore there's no place to go
and the muscles I say the community of
cells in the caterpillar break down make
a soup a soup of cells and then what and
here comes the important part
some of the cells are called imaginal
cells
and they have a vision of a different
organization a vision of a butterfly
so what's happening is the caterpillar
cells are breaking down the community
but the imaginal cells are taking those
cells and selling wait we've built
something better we build the butterfly
civilization is is destroying the planet
we can't do it anymore so it says what
you have the transformation you have to
go metamorphosis you have to change from
the voracious human civilization into a
civilization that has a light touch on
the planet and so I say so what it means
I say well in the Cocoon some cells are
breaking down some cells are being built
I say which which one do you want to be
with I say don't hold on to the one
breaking down because it's going to
break down let go of one that's breaking
down put your energy your effort your
action into building the better one that
was coming and so we're in the middle of
this chaos
which is coming down and being built up
and I said your health and your futures
depended on which one of these you want
to hold on to you want to hold on to the
caterpillar you're gonna die because the
caterpillar is death
and the Butterfly is live and so we're
facing at this moment with the breakdown
the jobs are being lost the economy is
crashing the whole world is in a shaking
okay in this moment of shaking you have
a choice and I say unfortunately too
many people oh I want the old one the
old one give it back to me the old one I
said the old one is the problem
and you gotta let go and I say you got
to have Harmony I get worse Army I go
vibration what's vibration I go music
you you're creating thoughts or
vibration that's when they put wires on
your head they read it called the
electroencephalogram they're reading
your mind I said what are they reading
vibration
I say so if you change the vibration
change the mind you get another world
and therefore vibration is the key
element of quantum physics
that determines if we're going to build
something or we're going to take
something down depends on the vibration
I mean the first step the first one was
so small and Irrelevant in one sense but
so powerful was I'm working on this
going oh my God I I've been programmed
and if I if I follow the program it's a
good program great but if it's a bad
program I'm going downhill and I
remember I was in my office at the
University and one of my faculty
colleagues came in that day and said
okay Bruce what are you bringing to the
faculty party on Saturday night I want
to tell you faculty party might as well
just kill yourself you go there and
everybody's sitting around with a drink
not talking to each other because they
don't really like it
okay and I thought about that and I
thought I work all damn week
why should I go to a stupid faculty
party and waste the entire time where I
had freedom to create something I would
love to do so on you know just came
right out of my mouth oh I'm sorry I
didn't realize it was this weekend I
have other plans I can oh I can't I
can't go this weekend I didn't have
plans but I just said that and he looked
at me like you're not going to The
Faculty party I go no and he walked out
and the moment he walked out he went oh
Saturday night for
me
what can I get rid of that I've been
programmed that this is what we do
socially even though it takes away
character quality joy out of life and I
started to eliminate them
and say wait I'm creating this I don't
want to give up my creation because
socially this is what we should do I
said I got my life man I want to live it
and I have been living a heaven on Earth
life
ever since those days why well with the
help of my partner Margaret who I met at
50 so 40 is a kid's age at 50. uh uh and
she she was quite aware of all the stuff
that I talked about we changed we
rewrote our programs beautiful and we
put together what 26 years now oh my God
honeymoon every day I wake up hey I'm
still alive I've got a great partner we
have a great life I work every day wake
up it's like wow I'm still here I'm
enjoying every day that I can get it's
called the honeymoon effect
forever wow how'd you do that I say get
rid of the programs that took the joy
away and replace them with programs that
give you Joy there's Bruce Lipton has
two two lives Bruce Lipton the guy who
lives in the house and goes to the store
and all that stuff okay and Bruce Lipton
a scientist I go what's the difference
I say Bruce Lipton a scientist knows
that from science we are facing our own
extinction because of our own human
behavior Bruce Lipton has a scientist
also knows this if you want to create a
world that we can live in and sustain
ourselves and be healthy we have to
change our Behavior because our behavior
is causing the problem so I also know
what does this mean it says the
structure has to break
to build a better structure a new
civilization because the foundation of
this civilization is creating all the
problems it's the culture and the way we
live with fear and hate and violence and
all that I go a garden which we came
from a garden is the height of
cooperation and we we live in the height
of of war and violence and all this
stuff we live in competition
and the idea is this then the belief
system of this civilization the fear the
competition the war all that stuff
that's part of our creation because
we're creating this physics
let's say you want to change the world
you've got to change the creation and we
have to break this structure because the
structure is perpetuating the problem
yes and this has to go in a chaos phase
let's break down yeah that's right so
science Bruce goes yep it has to break
down because that's how we're going to
build a new one and then Bruce the guy
who lives here goes what a mess is a
crazy mess of the scary
I'm living in Crazy mess but then Bruce
Lipton science comes in and says you
have to do this because the way you have
been living is causing the problem you
have to change
and that's easy to say but if you're out
there in the world as a working person
and everything and you have to
experience it's like it's falling apart
I go that scares people scares people
stress hormones stress hormones stop
thinking and listen to whatever they
said on a TV or the web don't think shut
down your your health why because I'm
running from that tiger because I am
scared and the point is then the health
issues got worse just watching the news
you walk away with a stress hormones
coming in they're like oh you just all
of a sudden made your system worse
because the stress hormones are going to
compromise you the things that you wish
for desire want in your life and you
have to work hard sweat over it I'm
putting a lot of effort in I'm gonna
make I'm gonna work I'm working on it
and I go why are you working so hard
okay is beautiful because whatever that
destination is you don't have a program
to support it and you're trying to
override a habit that doesn't give you
what you want by putting more effort
into it and I go good idea not good
process why 95 of your life is coming
from a program uh and five percent from
this little conscious mind up here
cannot mathematically if you think about
the subconscious a million times more
powerful programmer than the conscious
mind I say and you want to write
override the subconscious I go boy
that's a that's not gonna work
very well uh and yet there are ways to
do it because if it didn't this is going
to be a lousy interview but there are
ways to rewrite it and the idea about it
is
if you understand the process
you can rewrite your life and change the
outcome you can change these programs
sometimes in 15 minutes or less okay but
you need to know how to do it okay uh
the relevance about all this is um uh uh
the movie The Matrix uh it's all science
fiction I go no no no movie The Matrix
is a documentary what do you mean I go
premise everybody's been programming go
oh that's a given we are all programmed
from last trimester to age seven
everyone is but in the movie they say
well you can take a red pill and get out
of the program
and I want to suggest that most people
in our audience right now that we have
here today have taken the red pill at
one time or another and their life
profoundly changed okay when was that
one of the best examples is when people
fall in love I go what do you mean I go
well their life is blah blah blah blah
blah they fall in love they meet
somebody 24 hours later oh life is so
beautiful I'm so in love I'm so happy
look I'm glowing look I got growth
hormone in my system I go 24 hours later
after blah blah blah all those years and
24 hours later you manifest heaven on
Earth I go how'd that happen and the
answer is beautiful because the answer
is when you fall in love you stop
thinking you stay present it's called
staying mindful like what does that mean
I say when you're thinking is when the
subconscious autopilot kicks in if
you're not thinking then the conscious
creative mind is the one that's
manifesting your life so I go the moment
you fell in love why would you think and
the reason is this you've been waiting
for this person your whole life they
showed up you want to think and
disconnect from this I go no you want to
stay present you want to be mindful you
want to be there I go you stop thinking
I said what's the result
it's the red pill the moment you stop
thinking is you're not diverting to the
subconscious anymore you are operating
from conscious wishes and desires and so
the honeymoon is not an accident it's a
manifestation that says I'm not playing
the program you're being chased by a
saber-toothed tiger I say you you need
energy to to survive you have to run I
said where's the energy going to go I
said well Energy's in the blood that's
what carries the energy I say when the
stress hormones come in because the
tiger is chasing you
it does several things it shuts off the
blood flow to the the gut the viscera
that's not all the organs pancreas
stomach intestines I go it shuts off the
blood supply I say why I don't need to
fix and maintain the body if the tiger
is going to catch me and then I don't
that's a waste of my energy I want all
the energy go to my arms and legs Escape
so I say stress hormones shut off the
the mechanism of the viscera the growth
and maintenance of the body while you're
being chased
I said what else and here comes the one
that you were bringing up when when
we're really sick
you don't have a lot of energy to even
get out of bed because the immune system
uses a lot of energy to keep you healthy
I go so I'm being chased by a tiger
and I have a bacterial infection so I'm
putting energy in to run away and
putting energy into the infection I go
why do you worry about the infection
because if the tiger catches you the
infection is not a problem anymore
you're done okay so the this is the
point you brought up and this is the
most important point for the audience to
understand
stress hormones shut off the immune
system so that the energy can be used to
run away from the tiger before being
used to fight the bacteria uh and this
is the most important understanding
because stress is the cause of over 90
percent of illness on this planet
everyone thinks genes are causing
illness I go less than one percent of
illnesses connected to genes ninety
percent of illness is stress because
when you put the stress hormones in what
do they do they shut off the maintenance
of the body they shut off the immune
system and they even shut off the
intelligence
if the conscious brain the one up in the
front that's connected to you your
person is a slow processor like a slow
computer
the subconscious is like a super fast
if you're being chased by a tiger it's
not the time to think of oh
oh no run
and so the stress hormone shut down the
blood vessels in the forebrain where the
Consciousness is pushes the blood with
the energy to the hindbrain where
reflexes and reaction no thinking
because thinking is slow so I say so
then stress hormones do three things
number one they shut off the growth and
maintenance of the body number two they
shut down the immune system which
protects you from internal problem and
number three they make you less
intelligent
look at the look at the world today the
stress levels are overriding as I said
90 percent of illness is straight stress
not genetics it's lifestyle it's the
fear it's not living in harmony they
don't have enough good music to bring
Harmony into their world they're they're
on edge
I go well that automatically compromises
your health
in the year 2018 astronaut Dr Bruce
Lipton set out on a voyage to save
Humanity upon the assumption that Earth
was dying and humankind needed a new
home however just prior to launch new
studies emerged from Chernobyl the once
devastated landscape has regrown Nature
has returned unfortunately something
went terribly wrong and Dr Bruce Lipton
was sent into outer space many problems
occurred and Dr Bruce Lipton became lost
lost in the vastness of space
this is his journey
after 20 long years being Lost in Space
Bruce Lipton is finally coming home
oh wow what a welcoming sight look at
that beautiful blue green gem floating
in the darkness of space I'm going home
it's gonna be great now if I could just
get this ready for re-entry Mission
Control Mission Control astronaut Bruce
Lipton coming back home from the outer
limits with our beautiful rocket ship
please come in
I guess
maybe they're they're just busy right
now but my lab got such a great story to
tell them when I get back
[Music]
foreign
man being in that little can for 20
years out there this oh it's so
wonderful oh it's beautiful and it is
beautiful here God just think about how
much time I spent out there in open
space looking for another place for us
to live another planet and I come back
here and look at this it is so beautiful
I didn't ever have to leave gosh when I
left here this whole place seemed to be
falling down then the environment was
collapsing all around us the rain
forests were being cut down people were
destroying the air the water the land
look at it now wow these people have
really created something new ah created
something new well that's on an accident
that creation is a participation at that
time when I left in the world looked
like it was on its last stages something
happened they people must have learned
how to change the world but in order to
do that they first really had to learn
how to change themselves you really have
to understand at some level if we're
going to create a garden like this and
somewhere along the line we have to
create their own garden in our own
Consciousness first and that's where we
start to come from reality humans have
imagination they can imagine a garden
but then humans have the ability to
manifest recognize this you have 50
trillion citizen cells living under your
skin a community City that lives in
harmony if we really want to understand
how to live in harm and evil look within
that's where the answers are how can 50
trillion cells provide for a happy
healthy human being because they
understood the nature of community it's
a fractal universe and fractal Universe
simply means this a structure geometry
of the universe that represents As Above
So Below meaning if you understand the
structure at any level you can
understand it at any other level and so
if we really want to understand how to
create this beautiful planet then we
have to recognize this how do the cells
do it in our body because 50 trillion of
them came together in a community and
learned to live in harmony and provide
for their environment but then if we
understand how the cells did it then we
can understand how the people can do it
because we have to use the same
principles it's fractal to change that
planet and make it the garden that it
has become right now but then of course
you can't get there if you don't know
where you're going it's so before we
even embark on the trail we must first
visualize in our Consciousness what is
it we're seeking what are we trying to
manifest where are we going and once we
get that picture in our mind then we can
become the artist and manifest that
picture in the real world situation and
just by the looks of this Garden we
obviously must have learned our lesson
and of course where are these people
but where are these people
hello hello hello
you Maniacs you finally did it you blew
it up damn you oh the Hell
it's really interesting to understand
the difference in the dichotomy between
living and love and living in fear and
it's best to Illustrated if I put cells
in a Petri dish and I put nutrients in
front of the cells the cells will move
to the nutrients
but if I put toxins in front of the
cells the cells move away from the
toxins the significance is when you're
in a growth situation which is really
what love represents you're open because
growth is open to the world and you
assimilate things and that's where
growth comes from protection is just a
complete opposite protection means your
threat and your life is threatened and
you wall yourself off in protection so
growth is open and protection is closed
well the relevance is then you can't be
in growth and in protection at the same
time so in our normal history of biology
protection is a necessary part of our
survival you being chased by a
saber-toothed tiger you seriously have
to do something about this so what
Nature has done is created a protection
mechanism
in scientific terms is referred to as
the hypothalamic pituitary adrenal axis
very complicated abbreviated as HPA and
what this really represents is the
hypothalamus the part of the brain that
does an interpretation it looks at the
world and says am I in a safe place or
am I in a scary place if the
hypothalamus sees that we're in threat
of any kind it sends a signal to the
pituitary gland the master gland who
signals coordinate the activity of 50
trillion cells well in the case of a
threat the pituitary gland releases
hormones that activate the adrenal
glands the adrenal system is referred to
as fight or flight
so it's basically a protection mechanism
so I say okay great the HPA axis
hypothalamus sees the threat pituitary
coordinates 50 trillion cells and the
adrenal gland prepares for a protection
response well if you're being chased by
a saber-toothed tiger you're going to
have to use your arms and legs to run
away or fight what you need to do so the
system when under threat releases stress
hormones from the adrenal gland the
adrenal gland allocates all the energy
of the system to run away from the
saber-toothed tiger well that means the
first thing the adrenal gland activity
does is cause the blood vessels in the
gut to constrict this forces the blood
which has the energy to the arms and
legs but then you have to realize this
the moment you shut down the blood
vessels of the gut this is where growth
and maintenance and the necessary
control and stability of the body is
coming from the organs of the viscera so
when you're in a moment of threat you
shut down the energy going to this gut
because you're allocating the energy to
run away
that's one of the first things that
happens is we shut down growth and
maintenance of the body and people say
well growth I'm an adult I don't need to
grow and I go if we're made out of 50
trillion cells but every day we lose
billions hundreds of billions of cells
numbers that are just too big to
conceive of actually a normal attrition
aging damage and so basically it says
every day you're losing hundreds of
billions of cells that means by
definition every day you have to replace
hundreds of billions of cells so while
you don't see yourself growing every day
you are growing to match what you're
losing so if you shut down the growth of
the system it won't take very long for
the system to become in a state of
disrepair because if you're not
maintaining the replacement of those
cells this will lead to sickness and
disease and number two remember when the
threat is present the adrenal hormones
are released in stress they shut down
the immune system and this is an effort
to conserve energy to run away from the
tiger what's the result of being in a
state of protection the answer is you
shut down the growth and maintenance of
the body and you shut down the immune
system both of these if sustained for a
period of time will inevitably lead to
disease and death
and just to refer back again to the
nature of why Evolution gave us this
protection response to run away from the
saber-toothed tiger but once you run
away from it once you've made it away
from that tiger
then the system goes back into growth
again so by Nature's understanding
you're only supposed to use the stress
system for very short intervals of time
because it interferes with the normal
functions and then you look at today's
world and we realize 24 7 365 stress
hormones are being released into the
system we read the newspapers we watch
the news we're concerned about the world
and it's unfolding so what was supposed
to be only used for a very short time
has now become chronic and The Chronic
release of stress hormones has resulted
in an elevation with the amount of
disease and sickness that our planet or
this experience experiencing right now
so the significance is we must recover
and then to recover it says we must get
out of the fear that we live in because
fear kills how long does it take for a
baby to become independent well at least
13 years I go yeah but what happens in
the 13 years well the parents have to
help the child grow and learn and mature
so they can be independent parents yes
they have to stay together we
at least 13 years well how can you keep
two people together for 13 years after
the reproduction
Mother Nature creates the cocktail of
love the chemistry from the brain
chemistry that includes dopamine for
pleasure vasopressin for attractiveness
and oxytocin bonding bonding to that
loved one of yours for what at least 13
years so while the chemistry of Love
helps us stay together long enough to
raise our children it also is one of the
most wonderful aspects of human life on
this planet the chemistry gives us the
concept of compassion altruism love and
harmony that distinguish humans and this
beautiful experience is worth everything
and we should honor that on Valentine's
Day and that's why my job is to go
around the world and hit people with the
dart of love and I love my job because I
start to oh there's another couple hold
on oh here we go oh whoa good one yeah I
love my job bringing oh
oh oh my God I got hit with one of my
own arrows
oh I'm so in love
Margaret
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for some
incredible motivation from the one and
only Joe dispenza check the video right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there the only way you can do that is
you have to learn how to take all of
your attention off your body and become
a nobody take all of your attention off
all the people in your life that you
give so much of your attention and
energy to because you have an emotion
associate